Das war's für heute.
Das war's für KA30.
Was ist passiert?
Was biggest mistake?
Wo ist das Speccy?
Das war's für heute.
face also selbst wenn ich meine face ja reveal reveal wo haben wir es denn reveal
suppe wo ist die suppe wo ich mich reveal wo ist es denn mit das bild gar
nicht mehr reveal dass das halt in was ist denn das
32 x 32 ist dann halt ein bisschen klein so dann irgendwie man kann es gar nicht so
klein machen wie das dann wäre warum findet die windows suche eigentlich
nicht wenn ich nach reveal suche die windows suche ist so beschissen schlecht
das findet man nicht mal wenn ich noch reveal suche png das ist so lächerlich
schlecht
musst du erst so einstellen dass es funktioniert wie ich muss warum
funktioniert es nicht von haus aus totaler fail und jetzt und jetzt hängt
mein explorer erkomm ich mache zu dass man zu dumm ganz ab und ab gesehen ich
brauche es eh nicht und und warum warum kann der warum kann der in gifs warum
kann der in gifs nicht so er kann in gifs nicht so sogar meine komische sogar
mein selbst gestrickter gif player kann gif zoomen der keks ist viel ist auf so
viel zu fett das das sub icon das ist ja im endeffekt
was ist denn das 32 x 32 oder so
32 x 32 pixel da brauchst du irgendwas was das sind 32 x 32 pixel gescheit
aussieht weder der keks noch irgendwas anderes einfach nur das ich glaube nicht
dass das dass das gescheit aussieht man konnte man konnte höchstens das
augen nehmen so und es und es muss halt auch noch und es muss halt auch noch
quadratisch sein irgendwie na
irgendwie irgendwie so den ausschnitt oder so keine ahnung aber ich glaube
das erkennt man nicht wenn das so klein ist das sieht man nicht richtig
man müsste das man müsste das mal ausprobieren ich glaube nicht dass das
dass das ordentlich ausschaut weil das müsste noch viel kleiner sein das geht
jetzt kann man diese windows dinge nicht da mal das müssen noch viel kleiner sein
nur das gibt keine webseite webseite müsste es hier irgendwo hausen
das gibt eine fertige app die kann man sich dann downloaden
ich brauche ein paar leute das dann noch mal ausprobieren weil ich meine ich
habe jetzt ein paar test tracking number aber das ist halt von paketen die
schon angekommen sind damit kann man natürlich den status nicht so gut
tracken ein pok champ das immer mehr zu pok wird welche ein terabyte ssd
würdest du empfehlen hat mit den mit diesen mit den samsung dingern kannst
eigentlich nichts verkehrt machen also ich habe mir jetzt bei amazon prime bei
diesem bei diesem prime day habe ich mir eine moment habe ich jetzt eine 970 evo
nvm en 2 ssd bestellt die muss ich immer noch einbauen ich weiß da dieser prime
der ist jetzt schon eine weile her aber die ist glaube ich ganz gut war beim
prime die relativ günstig kostet jetzt ach so viel mehr hat die auch nicht so
viel so viel teurer ist die jetzt auch nicht
terabyte na ok doch dürfte so so 40 euro oder so war die
glaube ich billiger beim prime day ungefähr ist die tracking ab schon
fertig ich bin seit fünf minuten on sandwich maker
ich habe einen gekauft von ein paar jahren aber da ist kacke kann ich nicht
empfehlen der ist der ist müll den ich vor ein paar jahren gekauft habe da ist
schon vorne die lasche abgebrochen nach irgendwie 20 mal benutzen oder so was
sagst du zur crucial mx 500 ist auch ok habe ich ja auch zwei stück aber nicht
hier mpc
abgestern auch beim mixer reingeschaut da hat microsoft auch so viele funktionen
in der app nicht welche twitch hat könnte ich programmieren das verstehe
ich auch immer nicht wenn man nämlich dem service schon konkurrenz machen will
was die haben entwickelt mit hätte das gerade fast falsch ausgesprochen mit
mixer machen wollen dann verstehe ich immer nicht wie man quasi so funktionen
die die leute halt richtig geil finden nicht einbauen kann ich meine zumindest
haben die schon haben die emote support es sind halt nicht die twitch emote aber
ich was richtig cool also was was richtig big brain und next level wäre also
was richtig schwer wäre wenn mixer mit betta twitch tv und mit ffz wenn die mit
denen mal reden würden und dass die ffz und betta twitch tv emote quasi
included werden in mixer das wäre schon mal das wäre schon mal huge
warum alle gerade auf mixer so abgehen ich glaube es geht ehrlich gesagt kaum
einer auf auf mixer ab ohne addon genau direkt einbauen ich glaube es geht
keiner so wirklich auf mixer ab die einzigen leute die jetzt halt notgedrungen
auf mixer gehen sind die sind die ninja fans die weiter ninja gucken wollen aber
ich gehe ich habe es ja gestern schon gesagt ich gehe davon aus dass das
weil es gibt ja nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder führt das dazu dass mixer sich
voll durch setzt und ernsthaft twitch konkurrenz macht oder aber dass ninja an
bedeutung verliert die sache ist plus die ninja ist mittlerweile so groß ich weiß
gar nicht ob der überhaupt noch bindung an plattform so richtig nötig hat keine
ahnung der hat so viele so viele anhänger und fans so ganz so ganz in der
bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden wird er nie und hat auch massig youtube subs alles
aber ich glaube nicht dass ich mixer groß durchsetzen wird ich glaube eher
mixer wird genauso ähnlich unbeliebt bleiben wie die ganze zeit schon und
ninja wird einfach weniger zuschauer haben auf mixer was ein bisschen bitter
ist ehrlich gesagt für die leute die beispielsweise jetzt ninja schon
gesappt haben auf auf twitch für irgendwie zwei jahre und da ist jetzt
einfach mal so der sub weg also der zwei jahre sub weg
so das sei denn die verlängern den immer wieder auf twitch was auch beknackt
ist es würde twitch nicht also es wäre auf jeden fall nicht nicht schlecht wenn
es einen ordentlichen konkurrent gebe zu twitch aber was ich halt cool finden
würde ist wenn die wenn die twitch machen und halt das von twitch was
richtig gut ist einbauen es gibt ja es gibt ja kaum was auf twitch was so
richtig kacke ist wenn die das nehmen was twitch gut macht und einbauen und halt
noch sachen einbauen was sie irgendwie abhebt von twitch was wurde halt sagt
oder es ist ja nice mixer zu verwenden ich weiß ich weiß nicht was man da
machen könnte aber das ist auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mein job mir das auszudenken
wird sich die mixer dudes von microsoft ausdenken genau und youtube live das ist ja
einfach nur vorhanden das interessiert kein es gibt ja noch mehr es gibt ja
noch mehr ich meine es gibt noch facebook stream es gibt noch periscope
es gibt noch was you know nee doch tiktok haben wir auch noch heutzutage
was haben wir sonst noch die live das da wo pewdiepie streamt genau
daily motion das interessiert kein chatrubate
er gibt ja ein paar sachen aber nix in nix irgendwie im gesamtpaket was damit
twitch großartig konkurrieren könnte
mixerapp nur mit microsoft account schon mal fail
das zahle ich mir schon mal nicht
es gibt ein paar sachen nämlich an der twitch app auch abfangen aber im groß
und ganz ist die ok was mich am meisten ehrlich gesagt nervt ist an der twitch
app und an der youtube app dass es für ios keine alternativen apps gibt das
sagt ein bisschen für android gibt es welche weil mittlerweile nimmt mir auf
youtube zumindest die werbung überhand ich mache sehr gerne wenn ich wenn ich
abends im bett liegt dann mache ich mal youtube an problem ist du kannst youtube
gar nicht mehr anmachen abends im bett weil wenn du einpennst du wirst
instant durch werbung wieder aufgeweckt du machst irgendwas an was ein bisschen
länger ist und dann kommt da nicht nur mal werbung da kommt dann auch gleich
diese youtube double werbung hintereinander kenne das vor youtube jetzt
neuerdings doppelt werbung hintereinander abspielt weil weil es geht und das geht
mir auf den sack ja cheat eins sondern fünftes finde ich
auch bescheuert dass man überhaupt einen tool für den grafik treiber braucht das
ist wirklich beknackt
naja aber warten wir das ganze mal ab weil ändern können wir da dran nichts
da will ich auch gar nichts dran ändern da weiß ich was schön wäre wenn es eine
ordentliche alternative apps sowohl für youtube als auch für twitch für ios
gebe
weil ein einfacher blocker dns proxy einfacher dns blocker geht mittlerweile
nicht mehr also was wie p-hole oder oder erstes andere ad block dns oder so ich
habe vergessen wie das andere zeug heißt dass das bringt mittlerweile nicht mehr
und theoretisch würde nur noch helfe macht den proxy dazwischen aber nachdem
nachdem das ganze hat die ps ist wird es auch ein bisschen schwieriger ja
jude naja gut auf android hast du zumindest den vorteil du kannst dir das
apk so installieren ich meine klar das hat es bei den
noobs schwieriger allerdings ich kann mir auf ios noch nicht mal mit custom
ab seit lagen gescheit ich weiß gar nicht ob es eine gescheite twitch und eine
gescheite youtube alternativ ab für ios überhaupt gibt kann mir halt darauf
nichts seit lagen weil es nicht mein privates iphone ist sondern ich darf es
zwar privat benutzen aber noch das was die firma mir bereit stellt da und da
kann dann da kann ich nichts drauf seit lagen
ich weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt apps dafür gibt
ne online redaktor passiert in der regel nix
hat gefragt wenn man während des während des laufenden pcs auf das
mainboard oder die grafikkarte fast bekommt man anschlagen einer passiert in
der regel nix
wo ich aufpassen würde ist dort
irgendwelche metallgegenstände
oder oder
schrauben die reingefallen sind und das dann bewegen und über das mainboard
rollen lassen da würde ich ein bisschen aufpassen
kannst du wenn wenn es ganz doof läuft
was kurz schließen
ähm oder es kann jetzt netzteil rollen oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung das
muss nicht unbedingt sein
kann man ein youtube video im vollmittel laufen lassen aber gleichzeitig im
fenster modus wie soll das denn aussehen bitteschön
achja das geht mir auch auf ios auf den keks stimmt dass du fast nicht im
hintergrund abspielen kannst
ist das tracking tool schon fertig ne ich bin seit zehn minuten oder so
20 minuten wir haben wir haben nicht angefangen bis jetzt
kennst du die track ab auf telegram nö
auf welchen subreddits bist du unterwegs
auf allen möglichen data hoarder ist ganz interessant
pc master race
unix porn
was nichts damit zu tun hat wie sich der namen anhört
es gibt so viele subreddits
moin hast du nun mal nach dem neuen code geguckt ja ein bisschen optisch sieht
das schön aus
dass die minimap teilweise nicht da ist es komisch
es sieht schon ehrlich gesagt halbwegs ordentlich aus
ich bin mal gespannt ich mein kot das kommt ja immer wann kommt das immer
november
oder oktober
also ich gucke es mir wahrscheinlich dieses jahr mal an ich meine es schade
ist man gibt es eigentlich beta gab es august
ne irgendwann 20 august oder so
ach quatsch
september
ja das playstation 4 juckt mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht
ah early access
das lustige ist wahrscheinlich preorder ich das sogar
das spiel
mal gucken wo man das preordern kann
damit ich aber es muss eine plattform sein wo ich preorder cancelen kann
also ich preorder mir das dann
und cancel danach gleich wieder den preorder
oder aber wenn es nicht geht
wenn es nicht richtig funktioniert
mit dem preorder
und cancel
dann kaufe ich mir bei irgendeinem key shop
bei irgendeinem key shop für 50 cent
den beta zugang
jetzt bestimmt wieder gibt 100 pro wieder irgendwelche leute
die ihre die ihre beta codes verscherbeln
gab es jedes mal
kennst du einen guten gaming laptop für 1400 euro
ne gaming laptops kenne ich gar keine
im zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich eher kein alienware oder sowas
die dinger sind ja meistens ich meine die sind nicht schlecht aber meistens
viel zu teuer für das was drinne ist
so dann würde ich sagen fangen wir mal an
wie ich preview
ich habe so viel visual studio zeug mittlerweile interessiert
es kam jetzt gestern
oder vorgestern
kam
die dotnet core 3 preview 7
ach nee ist sogar schon eine woche her
raus
und
das sagt sogar microsoft zu
die kann man schon für projekte verwenden
die man quasi in nächster zeit vor hat
rauszubringen
also es gibt eigentlich
gar keinen so richtigen grund mehr
jetzt mit
dotnet core
was anzufangen
deswegen bin ich gerade überlegen ob wir das nicht einfach schon installieren
top installieren das einfach schon
wenn microsoft sagt es ist der bewahrt noch einen monat
das ist lustigerweise nur bei windows so bei diesen ganzen dotnet sachen geht
das eigentlich
was ist das denn ja das ist die neue dotnet version
aktuell ist 22 und das ist 3
und das wird die erste dotnet version
die 22 sachen ja klar die laufen ohne problem auf drei
das schöne ist
dotnet 3 ist ja die erste version
wo es wo quasi so der neue
der neue plan von microsoft
drinnen
anfängt also die haben ja geplant
dass sie alle dotnet version zusammenfassen wollen also sprich dass es
nicht mehr mono gibt kein dotnet core kein dotnet framework sondern das ist
alles
in dotnet core zusammenfließt
das haben sie glaube ich für dotnet core 5 oder so sich vorgenommen allerdings mit
mit 3 geht es jetzt zum ersten mal in die richtige richtung so dass man
angeblich kein normales dotnet framework man braucht
mit dotnet core 3 kann man windows anwendungen entwickeln sowohl wpf als
auch windows forms
und man braucht kein dotnet framework mehr
das geht auf jeden fall in die richtige richtung
er ist auch spielst du gerade gibt es irgendwas
was man kreuzer zeit spielen müsste
dann war mal hier den den
den installer
download gogo
btob
video spiele ich ja habe ich eben nicht mehr gespielt mittlerweile spielte
fabian in meinem account weiter
das heißt wenn ich wenn ich dann mal irgendwann online gehen in meinem account
ist er wahrscheinlich voll gemaxt und
und am cap
und jetzt geht euer bildschirm gleich wieder weg
weil er nach admin freigabe
okay moment
ich hoffe den bug fixen sie mal im obs
das denn wenn wenn admin dialog kommt nicht immer abkackt
overwatch
übrigens er hat so gesehen
es gibt jetzt in es gibt es auf dem ptr in overwatch gibt es jetzt 222 roll
queue
so und jetzt müssen wir hier noch mal nach unserem visual studio
review gucken wobei das kann man einfach aufmachen
und dann müssen wir da wahrscheinlich updaten
auf gogo
als tank willst du dich nicht anmelden
ja orissa ist also absolut meta zurzeit
obs als admin starten ja das kann schon sein aber das kann ja nicht sein dass
ich obs als admin starten muss dass das funktioniert
okay wir machen mal update
das aber ein komischer bug der guck mal jetzt ist nichts passiert ne
jetzt ist nichts passiert oder ist bei euch auch ist bei euch wieder weg
ne jetzt bei euch wieder da
obwohl ich nichts gemacht habe
ist es absicht dass irgendwelche recording tool zu den die es beim admin dialog
nichts machen können ja mit sicherheit ist es absicht
allerdings sollte es nicht schwarz werden
früher früher war es so es wurde es ist einfach kurz eingefroren
und dann ging es weiter
oder zumindest sollte es danach weitercapturen
aktuell in overwatch spielen sie halt alle
also may ist wieder übelst beliebt
und die spielen zum größten teil halt so ihr roadhog bunker zeugs da
das dann das dann sowas wie teilweise die war hauptsache hauptsächlich dass
allerdings roadhog orissa
manchmal siehst du noch in reinheit rumrennen das kommt aber relativ selten
vor
am meisten ist wieder knäbel sagt meistens hast du orissa roadhog may
als support hast du ana mercy
und dann hast du was hast du als was hast du als dps noch dabei
ob das ist war ja widower maker ist auch übelst übelst krass zur zeit
das wäre was für neaxe eigentlich
kannst du eine widower rausholen
kannst du alle skopen
wenn sie alle weg
weggeflickt
bähm fast
weggetrackt
hanso haben sie auch oft ja genau
es gibt ein paar
es gibt ein paar hellen die siehst du halt kaum
sowas wie reaper oder so
ganz selten
ganz auf ein vereinzelt auf manchen maps fahrer hast du so gut wie auch nicht
zymetra siehst du manchmal noch
zumindest sieht das ins film so aus
die spieler selbst nicht
man kommt eigentlich dein erstes rpg maker game raus
warum sollte ich den rpg maker game machen
aber diese sache mit was blizzard jetzt gemacht hat dass du dich 222 roll
kühlen kannst das ist wirklich endlich mal eine gescheite sage ich verstehe gar
nicht warum es so lang gedauert hat
das haben die leute in der beta schon gesagt
und es heißt ja nicht es ist ja nicht automatisch gesagt dass was die spieler
sagen
dass es sinnvoll immer ist
aber man kann es wenigstens ausprobieren
und es wäre sinnvoll gewesen
es sorgt für ordentlichere komps
und wahrscheinlich auch auf lange sicht für bessere balance
ich frage mich nur wie sie das in der overwatch league machen weil
die werden ja wahrscheinlich nicht
im ranked 222 einführen und in der overwatch league dann
weiterhin alles ist erlaubt spielen
also ich glaube nicht dass die
ja das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
die werden auf overwatch league dann auch auf 222 umstellen
oh goats geh mal weg
er nennt goatsong kenn ich schon
was ist 222
dass du dich im ranked jetzt entscheiden musst was du spielen willst
du dps tank oder support spielen willst
und
das matchmaking sucht sich automatisch zwei tanks zwei dps und zwei supporter
raus
und du kannst und darfst dann auch nur das spielen
also du kannst aber ich weiß gar nicht ob die anderen sachen gelockt sind
oder ob die anderen die das ausgewählt haben einfach nur
schneller picken dürfen
keine ahnung wahrscheinlich sind die sachen gelockt
was ja auch sinnvoll wäre
ach ja und was richtig nice ist
dass das matchmaking
also sprich dass der es eher abhängig von der rolle ist
das ist das ist recht das ist richtig nice
da kann man zum ersten mal
seit zweieinhalb jahren overwatch
tatsächlich mal was üben
mal angenommen ich bin richtig guter support oder vielleicht richtig guter
tank spieler
allerdings dps nur so mittelmäßig und ich würde
mich gern mit dps helden verbessern
dann ging das vorher nicht
du hattest du hattest ne
den sr
und du musstest das spielen was du gut konntest weil
sonst hast du dein team verarscht quasi und und
dein sr
auch
irgendwo
dass du konntest nicht üben das war lange zeit ein richtiges problem in overwatch
und jetzt kannst du jetzt kannst du zum ersten mal üben
kannst du zum ersten mal üben jetzt kannst du sagen ich bin jetzt zwar tank
irgendwie 4k
aber dps irgendwie nur 3,5 oder 3k
ich spiele jetzt mal ne weise dps und da hat es keinen einfluss auf dein
anderes ranking
und du kommst halt nicht in grandmaster games wenn dein dps eben nicht grandmaster
ist oder kommst nicht in top 500 games wenn dein
dps nicht top 500 ist
das ist eigentlich ganz nice
ich glaube ich installier es mir echt mal wieder
ich hatte es mir ja schon installiert
und dann habe ich ein stream angemacht und das erste was ich gesehen habe war 2cp und hab
wieder deinstalliert
man muss halt sagen das overwatch hat schon
ein paar helden die übertrieben bock machen
warte noch bis 222 rauskommt
ja ja ich spiele wenn schon nur auf dem ptr ein bisschen ein bisschen
ich spiele garantiert nicht dass
ohne roll cue
overwatch hat schon ein paar geile helden lucio ist übelst nice anna ist übelst nice
roadhog ist übelst nice
zarya ist übelst nice es gibt schon ein paar richtig geile helden und die sind auch
richtig gut durchdacht und machen übelst bock
anna ist eigentlich so mit der held der am meisten spaß macht wenn man gut spielen kann
lucio ist auch nice aber anna ist schon
ne skillnummer höher als lucio spielen
restart
microsoft willst du mich verarschen?
restart weil ich virtual studio geupdatet hab
big brain
ok dann starten wir das ganze mal
dann machen wir jetzt ne
wir machen ne
.net con 3
hsp.net web
anwendung
weil microsoft sagt das ist live ready
und ich hoffe
dass wir haben wieder nicht so viel geändert
dass ich wieder die sache nicht finde
ich glaube ich installiere nachher mal overwatch aber nicht on stream
und probiere mal auf dem ptr ne runde
nehm ich mir irgendwie 3 overwatch accounts
nehm ich mir irgendwie mal
oder sogar 4
werd ich mir dann mal angucken
sieh mal hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert
keine ahnung
ich als spieler nicht und aus videos erkennt man zu wenig kann ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen
ok also wie nennen wir das ding jetzt mal
versand tracksor
das ist doch mal ein name den kann man sich merken
und so heißt garantiert noch nix anderes
trackermonks
ok was kann man hier eigentlich mittlerweile alles auswählen
grpc asp9courser ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
also ich weiß was rpc steht allerdings für was was ist grpc ist es eine google geschichte oder
oder ist das
also ich würde sagen wir machen ein api projekts
https wer braucht sowas denn
was haben wir sonst zur auswahl angular app react js app
kammer gibt's gibt's gibt's in viewed gibt's in viewed template mittlerweile das müssen wir mal kurz schauen das wäre eigentlich gar nicht ganz gucken wir mal
da nicht
da müssen wir selbst einbinden
also wir machen eine api
api anwendung ohne irgendwelche sperenzien
der versand tracksor
warum warum haben manche
warum haben manche hier chillstep sonst was playlist immer
komische voice sample sachen drin
es geht mir immer voll auf den keks wenn ich erzähle im hintergrund in der musik labert jemand
warum haben sie eigentlich den witcher hintergrund
na gut 2017 da war das angesagt
wettervorhersage
ok was auch immer das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein
test
ja das ist das ist das test
so wie halt die anwendung kommt oder beziehungsweise wie halt das template
kommt dass man ausprobieren kann
k
kann man damit auch sehen wie lange die game a girl badewasser liefern dort ja
warum macht jetzt erstmal
30 browser auf
kann das sein dass das irgendwie ein bisschen rum
ah moment moment meine andere anwendung
meine andere anwendung läuft auch auf dem gleichen port kann das sein
am ende mal
glaube dass ich glaube jetzt kommt da gerade ein bisschen durcheinander
die zwei anwendungen auf dem gleichen port ab hier 5000
das ist
das ist ja auch ein geiles template
geiles template startet die beispiel anwendung und sie geht nicht
hier dann starten wir das hier noch mal ohne ohne die back und gedöns
was spakt ist
also ok alles gut
doch geht's jetzt
jetzt geht nämlich noch ein browser auf
allerdings macht er voll das falsche
voll die falsche urlaufe
also das template ist noch nicht so ganz ausgereift würde ich sagen
auf welchen fahrt muss ich denn slash ap
slash
besser vorkast
da geht doch
ok also das beispielprojekt kann man mal voll in die tonne kloppen
wir ändern das jetzt ganz normal lounge settings
wir wollen
direkt wir wollen nichts spezielles aufrufen wir wollen das einfach
direkt auf
gut starten und gut ist da gibt es natürlich noch keine seite drauf das ist
irgendwie klar
diesen ganzen wettervorhersagen beispielkram schmeißen wir weg
brauchen wir nicht
den controller lassen wir mal da
schauen wir uns mal an
ah ne den controller lassen wir nicht da
den schmeißen wir auch weg
dem ist ich
start-up also das müssen wir uns
oh das sieht anders aus als vorher
da haben sie ein paar sachen
ok da haben sie ein paar sachen geändert im vergleich zu
dot net core 22
das sieht anders aus
use authorization brauchen wir schon mal net
use routing
oder sowas machen wobei das brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht
okay lass was mal so lass was mal so was wir auf jeden fall brauchen ist wir
brauchen ein ordner für unser html gedöns
ja wie gut
und da brauchen wir
index html drinnen
index
index html
blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
mal gucken ob das jetzt schon aus reicht ich vermute mal nicht
das ist asp.net core
nein das reicht noch nicht aus
ähm wir müssen nämlich noch sagen dass der überhaupt die sachen aus
www root
use file
bereit stellt
das geht das gar nicht
so jetzt sollte es funktionieren wenn das noch so funktioniert wie letzte
version ja da ist es ja
blub blub blub blub
ok nice funktioniert
das muss ich mal durchlesen
was gibt das ist auf jeden fall neu in asp.net core 3 das war vorher nicht so
das hat man anders gemacht
add controller als add service
das ist glaube ich die ist das die leichtgewichtige variante zu use mwc
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist das
ja schauen wir mal
dann brauchen wir noch brauchen wir noch ein paar ordner nämlich brauchen wir hier noch einmal
models
und äh
data
und jetzt brauchen wir noch für sqlite die ganzen datenbank
abhängigkeiten
das schlimme ist ich weiß mittlerweile fast auswendig wie der ganze ganze Mist heißt
microsoft
entity framework core
oder auch nicht
habe ich verschrieben
und wie heißt der kram fack
jetzt habe ich so groß so habe ich so das hieß das hieß es nicht so
wir suchen jetzt mal sqlite
viele sachen wird es da nicht geben
vielleicht haben sie jetzt auch unbedingt ef core oder so
entity framework core ist jetzt hab das habe ich doch geschrieben
microsoft
in alt nervt nicht rum
ist nicht geschrieben
na gut was auch immer dann können wir es dann installieren wir es halt von hier
gucken ob die suche kaputt ist oder
ob ich mich einfach verschrieben ich glaube ich habe mich verschrieben wahrscheinlich habe ich verschrieben
ja das ist richtig ppega suche hier
so sqlite soll ich installieren
weil wir brauchen bisschen datenbank brauchen wir ja
omegalool
einfach nur so
jetzt kratternach
weil das glaube ich entity ist also ja das kann natürlich sein dass ich da verkackt habe
das kann natürlich sein
da kann man sich schon mal verschreiben ja ich accepte
ich glaube ich habe mich einfach verschrieben ich habe mich aber ich habe mich wahrscheinlich verschrieben
denke ich war ich werde mich auch verschrieben haben ok
service
use sqlite
war das ein service
sqlite
use sqlite war das hier
warte mal erst mal überlegen wo war das das war
und bei mir
das wusste man hier gar nicht machen
das war das muss man ganz früher machen jetzt muss man überhaupt nicht mehr
machen
man muss jetzt man muss den
db kontext anlegen
und da drin sagen man möchte sqlite verwenden
mal gucken
wie gut mittlerweile das automatisch generieren von solchen sachen ist
aber wir legen jetzt erstmal unser model an für unsere
pakete
class
und das ding nennen wir dann mal das nennen wir einfach mal ganz normal
also wir können shipment oder package nennen
was sind denn sinnvollere name
also im prinzip die klasse wo drin steht
über welchen versandanbieter das ganze verschickt wird
ähm wanns zuletzt geupdatet wurde
und was dann auch wieder link auf die auf die history hat
shipping ist glaube ich kein guter klassen name
china shipment
aber wir nennen es wie nennen es shipment ist
so da brauchen wir sowas wie ein
carrier das ist dann sowas wie dhl oder so
ja ja publik enum
haben wir letztens schon mal alles gemacht deswegen wissen wir jetzt schon
ganz gut was wir da alles brauchen
wir haben den carrier das ist
dhl
amazon sorry amazon natürlich amazon
herrmus
ups und dpd
supporten wir startmäßig erstmal
ja carrier
dann brauchen wir sowas wie die eigentliche die eigentliche
eigentliche tracking nummer brauchen wir
gibt es ein schönes wort für
weil tracking
tracking nummer tracking number ergibt ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn weil
das ist keine number das besteht aus buchstaben und aus zahlen also ist
eigentlich keine keine
keine nummer
code
tracking id
tracking id finde ich gut
wobei ich code auch nicht verkehrt finde
so barcode oder so aber das ist ja kein barcode
dann brauchen wir
was was
machen wir mal als erstes hier hin
so ein idfeld braucht jede
klasse die man mit entity framework verwenden will sonst sagt er ohne id geht
nix
das ist baro hat hier gains gemacht
dann brauchen wir sowas wie
created
das ist created adn ist noch so ein bisschen übrig gebliebene ruby
angewohnheit
wahrscheinlich sollte man einfach nur created nehmen
created nennen
so also das ist im prinzip hier kommt der timestamp rein wann das ding angelegt
wurde weil ich mein
es kann ja auch mal sein
dass man sich vertippt
wenn man sich vertippt hat
oder man oder vielleicht auch der scanner aus der mail die falsche
ne tracking nummer extra die es gar nicht gibt
dann kann ich sagen ok
wenn das ding innerhalb von sieben tagen
ab erstelldatum
keine keine tracking infos findet
dann stellen wir das auf nicht findet nicht auffindbar oder so
kommt created ad und update nicht ausschauen aus entity framework
das kann sein dass das entity dass das das alte entity framework das gemacht
hat aber er macht das nicht
nicht dass ich wüsste dass es das macht
so was braucht man sonst noch created ad
so und jetzt wird es ein bisschen komplizierter weil jetzt bräuchten wir sowas
wie ne
das wird keine stringlist ich schreibe sowas wie ne history bräuchten wir jetzt
sowas wie ne history
dazu brauchen wir ne neue klasse die heißt dann
shipment progress oder so
so und meine history besteht aus
einzelnen ein fortschrittseinträgen
also da habe ich dann zum beispiel in meiner history
fünf einträge für
für wann halt ein event aufgetreten ist und nach dem motto
ist jetzt unterwegs an diesem standpunkt ist jetzt unterwegs an diesem standpunkt
ist jetzt unterwegs dahin
ist jetzt im auto wird ausgeliefert und ausgeliefert
so das werden wir in fünf einträgen halten der history
progress so und jeder progress hat
selbst mal wieder ein
updated ad
ein
eine message
also wo der text drin steht so nach dem motto
das paket wurde wurde in das zustellungsfahrzeug geladen wie es bei
dhl immer drinne steht
ähm
und was was braucht man sonst noch
den status brauchen wir noch also was das gerade was das gerade ist
also in in transit
im im auto
ist get und send eine abart von dotnet
das ist keine abart das ist eine kurze schreibweise
für ansonsten nervige sachen
also du kannst das also das ist die kurz schreibweise ich glaube man kann es
gibt mittlerweile auch so ein refactor für das für ein macht
das ist die kurz schreibweise von
kammer kammer das kammer das nicht mehr
ach doch hier
die richtig lange schreibweise geht glaube ich gar nicht mehr
das ist die lange schreibweise
das ist die lange schreibweise davon
du hast ein backing field private backing field und das ist dann quasi
das public property wurde drauf zugreift auf dieses
das ist einfach nur die kurze schreibweise davon
macht im prinzip genau das gleiche spart aber ganz viel geschwuppel
so message
dann brauchen wir sowas wie status
so und status wird sowas sein wie
brauchen wir noch mal ein enum
sowas wie
status
ähm
das das hatten wir schon mal das sowas wie transit
delivery das hatten wir schon mal in unserem dhl tracker
dann hatten wir es genannt da kann ich mich doch daran erinnern
der aus kennen fuchs hat abonniert dankeschön
unser css pro
kein css pro sondern css pro ist das
poggers
fritz prime dafür habe ich doch jetzt sogar einen eigenen sound
aber für extra doch dafür angelegt
so ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben
ähm wir brauchen status dazu brauchen wir hier einen
wieder einen enum so und eine sache die wir noch einführen wie ich nenne es mal stale
ähm
ist ein stand status den wir verwenden können
mal angenommen
irgendjemand edit was
und
man findet einfach eine gewisse zeit keine keine sende verfolgungs information
zu
dann können wir es auf stale stellen
das ist halt oder oder vielleicht fällt hier jemandem noch ein schöneres
schöneres wort für ein
dann stellen wir den status nämlich einfach auf stale so nach dem motto
das ist irgendwas nicht so ganz richtig mit
findet dazu keine sende information
man könnte ja quasi sagen
sowas wie
ähm
also hier das man stellt auf stale wenn
innerhalb sieben tage nichts gefunden wurde
oder error counter irgendwie größer zehn
da könnte man so machen wenn das ding älter als sieben tage es wurde nix gefunden
oder aber
wenn beim suchen nach dem sendecode irgendwie zehnmal einen fehler gab dann
stellen wir das auf ist wahrscheinlich verkehrt
paket verloren status ich glaube das kriegen wir nicht abgezapft richtig
einheitlich
ich beschränke mich mal auf die sachen die auf jeden fall einheitlich von
jedem anbieter kriegen können
nämlich dass das ding unterwegs ist dass das ding im auto ist und dass das ding
fertig ist
und dass das ding
nicht gefunden wurde
dass die nummer falsch ist
und die zwei sachen die diese vier sachen werden wir wahrscheinlich bei
jedem anbieter raus kriegen
ähm
hallo bietbrot
das reicht eigentlich erst mal
dann legen wir jetzt unseren app-kontext an
da will ich ja mal ausprobieren ob
ob man ob dieses ähm
das war bisher immer ziemlicher Mist
ob man ob dieses code generieren mittlerweile in visual studio ganz gut funktioniert
probieren wir mal aus also was wollen wir
api controller mit actions
using entity framework
brauchst du das ganze noch abstrakt also mit interfaces kommt drauf an was man
da noch alles braucht
also die
eigentlichen paket tracker die kriegen auf jeden fall ein interface weil
das
sind ja
mindestens mal vier verschiedene paket tracking sachen die wir brauchen
und das muss man ja irgendwie einheitlich machen über den interface
oder über irgendeine base class oder irgendwie sowas
müssen wir mal gucken
ok api controller mit actions using entity framework mal gucken wie gut die code
generieren mittlerweile funktioniert
model class ist unser
shipment
data context class wollen wir uns eine erstellen lassen
die heißt versandtracksor-kontext
abdb-kontext das ist so der noobname den alle nehmen
wenn ihnen nichts einfällt und die wollen wir allerdings in data erstellen
ich bin irgendwann mal so angewöhnt ich weiß gar nicht ob das
krasse best practice sind da so zu machen
moin wie ist die lage
also aktuell funktioniert alles aber wir haben noch nicht all zu viel gemacht
so mal gucken ob
code generieren ordentlich funktioniert
die was hier los
warum warum darf sich warum darf sich wirklich
was ist los brischel studio
warum darfst du dich vor meiner overlay schieben
was hier los warum darf der das
mein overlay ist always on top eingestellt
ok
vs zeigt dominanz
genau
könnte man echt so interpretieren
oder man könnte es auch so interpretieren
oh das habe ich vergessen
man könnte es auch so dominieren vscode zeigt ppega dominanz
das habe ich vergessen das stimmt ja
das ding braucht auch noch eine id
und funktioniert es nicht
weil hier haben wir das
hier verwenden wir die klasse drinnen ohne id kann er die ja nicht in der
datenbank anlegen
das stimmt
da gebe ich ihm recht das funktioniert nicht
microsoft eins maxnull
ok also machen wir das ganze noch mal
model class
add
app
db context
in data
wo es jetzt funktioniert
zweimal kontext
monka shake
abbrechen geht nicht
ab db kontext kontext
aber das ist kein ding man kann es einfach unbedingt
zack
und schon
heißt er richtig
unter data hat er es jetzt angelegt
also dass er den kontext darunter angelegt hat ist ok
dass er den controller darunter na gut ich habe hier auf den ordner geklickt
ok wir moveen das ganze mal
wir moveen das ganze mal hier unter controllers
ah
und jetzt ändern wir noch den namespace in controllers
jetzt meckert er natürlich rum dass er es nicht findet
ah alles gut
so und das ding
wir nennen wir um ich nenne das ding immer ctx weil
also angeben
sehr schön
ja so das code generieren funktioniert ganz anständig
ok was hat er da was hat er uns da alles generiert
also unter slash api slash controller name also
also api slash shipments
haben wir jetzt einen controller der uns
auf dem index als index gibt er uns alle shipments zurück das ist richtig das
sollte man an
die default standard so
ähm
ein get auf eine id gibt uns das einzelne
shipment mit dieser id zurück das ist auch ok
das ist alles schon ziemlich modern gemacht hier mit mit task mit task
action result und und und
schön im await
find a single alles
viel ordentlicher als ich das gemacht hätte wieder das generiert hat
put für ein update auf die id ist auch implementiert
verwende ich so gut wie nie ehrlich gesagt
ähm
post zum neuen anlegen
die liet mit der id
und so eine testmethode ob das ding
existiert
wir schmeißen die sachen weg die man nicht brauchen gleich aber erst mal
lassen wir das so wie es ist
ok so jetzt müssen wir erstmal
unsere webseite basteln ähm unsere webseite machen wir mit ähm
machen wir mit visual studio code auf
achso vorher laden wir uns noch mal ein paar bildchen runter
dhl logo
machen wir mal hier add
links hier image
die mage
so ein dhl logo was nehmen wir da ein kleines brauchen wir nicht high resolution
wir brauchen ein kleines
eiken eiken klingt gut
128 128 128 das klingt
nicht gut
ähm
265 und 256
also 128 mal 128 wäre mir eigentlich lieber
aber das ist nicht transparent
und da ist ganz da ist
weißes zeugs drum herum
sagt irgendwie ne
hier da haben wir noch was das ist doch gut
das nehmen wir
dhl
dhl logo und dann machen wir noch hermos hermos logo
oh hermes gibt es auch handtaschen ok
hermes logo
und warum sieht das warum sieht das hermes logo so schlecht aufgelöst aus
können die können ihr eigenes logo dann immer ein ordentlicher
nehmen wir mal das das sieht ganz brauchbar aus
so save
hallo clocks hd
was hältst du eigentlich von spring boot auch wenn du ja warst
ganz ehrlich meine erfahrung mit spring boot halten sich ziemlich in
grenzen ich weiß was es ist
das ist quasi so einen
so so
wo ich bisschen bisschen weiter ausruhen früher war es ja irgendwie so
du hast da ein java zeug in irgendeinem applikationsserver wie tomcat laufen
lassen und ich glaube spring boot ist es jetzt quasi
umgedreht
dass du quasi deinen eigenen applikationsserver irgendwie mitbringst
also dass du quasi jetzt
nicht dein java im tomcat laufen lässt sondern quasi den tomcat im java laufen
lässt so
korriert mich wenn das wenn das nicht stimmt
aber so in der richtung habe ich das bei uns mitbekommen
das wohl eben einfach ein anderer ansatz ist
und anscheinend
sehr beliebt in der java welt
mehr weiß ich dazu nicht
außer dass es wohl
nicht schlecht sein kann
weil das viele unserer entwickler ganz doll finden und da sind auch ein paar
dabei
vereinzelt
obwohl es java programmierer sind
den trau ich tatsächlich einiges zu
so hier hermes
als nächstes save image
dhl
reicht jetzt hermes und dhl logo
so dann machen wir diff
all die
da drinnen brauchen wir eine form
action
slash ap
slash
shipments
post
so da haben wir eine form
da was was im chat wieder los
ok action shipments das ganze muss man überlegen ob wir das als jason oder als
wir schicken das mal als form
data
so und jetzt was brauchen wir also wir machen jetzt mal zwei sachen
wir machen eine liste hier unten
wir machen eine liste mit allen
mit allen
laufenden wir machen tabelle wir machen tabelle
mit allen laufenden
auch mache ich das überhaupt in in in durch das studio ich hab doch gesagt ich
will das in
das in force code machen
open folder
ok weg damit weg damit
index
das war schon gleich viel angenehmer
weil dann kann ich
mein backend krempel in visual studio machen und den frontend kram mach ich in
force code und muss mich da nicht so viel
da nicht so viele gedanken drum machen
hat es auch ein table template
braucht man eigentlich auch nicht
so also
was ich jetzt vorhabe ist ich ich würde gerne
eine form machen zum neuen anlegen von tracking nummern
asp oder blazer
naja blazer ist
du brauchst ja auf jeden fall in den back end also in der regel verwendest du blazer mit
asp
also hier oben machen wir
den input wo man eine neue tracking nummer eingeben kann und einen anbieter
auswählen
wie gesagt
plan ist ja dass man sowohl manuell tracking nummern hinzufügen kann als
auch
automatisch
dass der automatischen email postfach scan nach tracking nummern aber
wir machen es mal heute zum zum dass man so grundsätzlich mal was
funktionieren das hinkriegen
dass man es von hand edit
und wenn das funktioniert und im hintergrund updated ist ja das automatische
scann dann
der nächste logische schritt
und unten drunter macht er eine tabelle
machen wir eine tabelle
mit den aktuellen einträgen und dem status
also
wie funktioniert er gerade noch mal tabel hetz th ne tabel ne warte mal
mach mal nochmal ordentliche tabelle
so ne tr
th
blub blub blub
mal gucken
mal gucken wie meine tabelle ausschaut
eh ja gut
ehm td blub blub blub
hatte ich hier nicht irgendwo ne
hatte ich hier nicht irgendwo den live reloadserver laufen
dass er das automatisch updated
na gut wir werden nicht sterben vor den appen zu mal refresh drücken
ok so
dann brauchen wir hier oben noch nen style
und zwar brauchen wir diesen
muss ich jetzt mal googeln danach
css table
second
genau sowas hier
das will ich haben
das ist jetzt nämlich
jede zweite
jede zweite reihe
jede zweite row in der tabelle kriegt eine andere farbe
ehm probier mal aus
ups
was mach ich denn
moment moment da stimmt was von der logik hernicht
ich brauch noch ne
zweite row
ja guck jetzt funktioniert das
so
ok ehm also was brauchen wir
wir brauchen ehm sowas wie wie nennen wirs mal
wir schreiben es mal auf deutsch sowas wie sendung brauchen wir oder paket
komm wir machen es englisch
so dann brauchen wir
ehm
status was der aktuelle status ist
also sowas wie
auf dem weg im auto oder oder zugestellt
dann brauchen wir sowas
ich glaub so viel brauchen wir hier gar nicht
dann brauchen wir sowas wie eh
updated
also und und und was für ein anbieter ist
das sieht jetzt natürlich extrem
hässlich aus
deswegen binden wir erstmal ne ordentliche schriftart ein
welche schriftart verwende ich denn hier ich glaub google gdns ne
kann man gleich schon mal einbinden
row proto schriftart beste
ach so titel brauchen wir auch noch versand
tracksor
so ehm
dann sagen wir jetzt
body soll
font family
kann ich das robotor oder so
wie das so
sieht schon mal viel besser aus
und font size
aber irgendwie zwanzig
wie das ausschaut
das sieht doch schon mal besser aus
moment mal leute ich muss mein live reload zeug mal konfigurieren das geht
mir extrem auf den keks
dass ich jedes mal
click to run live server
und jetzt ist euer bild wieder weg
aber vielleicht kommt ja euer bild jetzt gleich wieder
wie siehts aus leute kommt's bild wieder ne ne kommt nicht wieder
kommt's wieder doch kommt wieder
hat es jetzt
eh es funktioniert nice
ah moment moment moment das kann nicht funktionieren
das geht jetzt ja
der muss das proxy ne
auf fack wie macht man das mit dem live reload server jetzt richtig
ich mein guckt prinzipiell funktioniert es jetzt wenn ich jetzt hier was ändere
und speichere dann update es automatisch
allerdings ist das ein eigener server der nicht weiterleitet zu zu meinem
eh backend ding also das heißt das kann nicht richtig funktionieren
eh
glaube das ist wieder viel komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
live reload server
first code proxy
der muss das jetzt irgendwie proxyn dass das funktioniert
proxy proxy proxy gibt seine
doch kann man bestimmt wenn ich wüsste wie
proxy
live server
settings proxy to enable proxy settings proxy
proxy url
das sieht eigentlich ganz
brauchbar aus
settings
dem jetzt können wir wieder rausschmeißen
so also was war
die settings die sehen doch sonst irgendwie anders aus oder
heute was ist denn da los das ist doch gar nicht die richtest gar nicht das
richtige setting
ah das da meine ich genau also was brauchen wir jetzt live server live
so hier
was muss man als einstellen proxy proxy
ah nice der kopiert einem gleich denn das beispiel live server settings enable true
wir wollen alles proxyn und zwar auf
wohin wollen wir proxyn auf localhost auf localhost 5000
mal gucken ob der kam jetzt funktioniert da bin ich mal gespannt
das jetzt ob das jetzt geht
scheint oder funktioniert das jetzt
na gut werden wir gleich sehen ob das funktioniert
wir müssen mal ein request machen gucken wir mal
ob es funktioniert anscheinend aber es aktualisiert nicht mehr
bin verwirrt
es hat funktioniert aber es hat nicht aktualisiert
wenn ich jetzt hier ändere dann update jetzt nicht mehr
denn das ist ja fail dann brauche ich den kram auch nicht
kann er doch netzserver tls ja
jetzt proxyt er zwar aber aber aber aber reloadet nicht mehr
wozu brauche ich das dann
ist es vielleicht verkehrt ist das vielleicht falsch wie ich das mache
freeload will fully controlled by the live server web extension
probieren wir mal aus vielleicht gehts ja damit dann besser
dann machen wir es halt nicht im da machen wir es halt nicht im
das funktioniert jetzt ich glaube es geht ich glaube es geht ich bin mir nicht so ganz
sicher ob das jetzt wirklich das ist was ich haben will
vielleicht gehts jetzt auch auf dem server
das geht jetzt nur wenn ich auf dem richtigen server auch bin
ok was auch immer aber prinzipiell scheint es zu gehen
ok gucken wir mal schauen ob das ganze das war auch schon mal einfacher
ja ja ich habs gestartet ja klar port 5500
also da ist immer die world drinne wo der aktuellste download ist
da zack ok dann machen wir mal ein bisschen was dynamisches
script app gleich new view zack zack zack zack so data element wo die app geladen werden
soll app und mounted mounted also sprich das ist die funktion die einmalig ausgeführt
wird wenn das ding geladen wird schauen wir mal ob es irgendwie abkackt
oder so oder ob das funktioniert failed achso fafikon wen juckts dann
view wird geladen das heißt es wird auch ordentlich geproxied
das ist schon mal schön zu sehen so data data brauchen wir jetzt ein
shipments array ich denke mal wie immer nur laut ne
so und das ganze müssen wir jetzt abrufen von unserem von unserem backend
der backend hat allerdings muss ich doch mal ausmachen
unser backend close kann man den auch sagen kann man dem auch sagen dass der
nichts starten soll ja hier launch browser falls brauchen wir nämlich nicht
weil wir haben wir hier unseren eigenen tap ist viel besser sondern kein browser
starten so wir haben jetzt allerdings weder die
datenbank angelegt noch was hat der da eingefügt use sql server
ne ne ne ne use sq lite wollen wir haben übrigens habt ihr es gesehen das ist
ein neues feature von visual studio 2019 habe ich jetzt verkehrt ich brauche
das hier hinten gar nicht das ist ein neues feature von visual studio 2019
was haben sie den riesen aufrist drunter gemacht
drüber gemacht in in einem in einem build video dass diese diese auto
completion die hier vorgeschlagen wird also quasi mit was die beliebtesten
metoden sind aus diesem aus diesem framework dass sie das mit super krass
im hochkomplexen maschinen learning rausgefunden haben und jetzt quasi diese
super neue tolle bleeding edge technologie endlich ihren benutzer
zur verfügung stellen ich weiß nicht genau wozu man da maschinen
learning braucht das wahrscheinlich reicht es nicht einfach zu zählen wie oft
welche also welche methode besonders oft verwendet wird aber aber maschinen
learning herzig hat sich auf jeden fall gut an ja so und jetzt müssen wir
nämlich noch einstellen dass der überhaupt unser sq lite verwendet so
kontext als erste was wir noch machen müssen sicherstellen dass die
datenbank angelegt ist
ok und jetzt müssen ab db kontext kontext immer noch einmal kontext so viel im
dateinahmen hat und müssen ihm sagen das brauche man nämlich gar nicht mehr ich
habe jetzt gelesen man macht das jetzt unter man macht es jetzt anders unter
sp dort net core drei macht man das jetzt anders und zwar man überschreibt
jetzt on configure und dann sagt man option bilder use sq lite was da dran
jetzt besser ist als das in im start up zu machen keine ahnung aber es ist
besser shipments punkt db
so und nun sollte der eigentlich wenn ich wieder starte datenbank anlegen
sq lite datenbank anlegen
und dann sehe ich allerdings immer noch nichts probieren wir mal es sollte sehr
sq lite datenbank zumindest schon mal anlegen
ich sehe als verhältnismäßig wenig ehrlich gesagt
dann nicht ein bisschen mehr stehen müssen
ne da hat die angelegt die datenbank da ist sie ja
open in explorer please open in explorer wir gucken wir gucken wir rein wie die
aussieht sq lite haben wir hier unseren sq lite broser der der braust so was
haben wir da drinne shipment shipment progress und data ist logischerweise
nichts drinne weil wir noch nicht hinzugefügt haben das datenbank anlegen
hat funktioniert nice auch wenn er keine die keine debug ausgabe gemacht hat
einmal wollen sie aber nicht so anstellen ok datenbank anlegen hat
funktioniert das heißt dann probieren wir doch jetzt einfach mal was zu
erstellen oder wie erstellen nichts wir schreiben wir schreiben ein test wir
schreiben ein test eintrag machen wir rein direkt beim starten der anwendung
dass man die dass wir unsere web dass wir unsere web interface auch was sehen
nämlich hier x database also wir wir löschen die wir löschen die datenbank
und legen sie danach wieder neu an das heißt das ding ist jedes mal leer und
dann fügen wir fügen wir mal was neues an test test shipment hinzu und gucken
ob das funktioniert oder nehmen wir eine tracking nummer die uns jemand letztens
im stream zur verfügung gestellt hat probieren das damit aus so carrier ist
nehmen wir mal dhl created ad ist datetime nao history haben wir noch
id macht er selbst und tracking id ist die muss ich mir raussuchen die habe ich
hier in meinem notizprogramm gespeichert vom letzten stream
ohne test wer schreibt schon ein bisschen kommen jetzt ernsthaft abdem ich schon
einmal den test schreiben sehen im stream ich glaube einmal ich glaube sogar
einmal haben wir den test gemacht aber normalerweise haben wir nie tests weil
wir immer fehlerfrei programmieren aber keine tests so nehmen wir mal die
tracking nummer wir gucken erst mal wir testen erst mal ob die geht
und tracking da ja shipment nach hannover
ist übrigens danke für alle die mit der test tracking nummer zur
verfügung gestellt haben jetzt jetzt brauche ich so ok das haben wir jetzt
drinne shipment safe safe wofür braucht man eine datenbank wenn man eh keine
daten nach einem stoppen der applikation hinterlässt ja dann dann brauchst du in
der regel auch keine datenbank je nachdem was du dafür beziehung zwischen
deinen daten hast vielleicht schon oder zumindest in memory damit dann brauchst
du in der regel keine aber wäre auch rechtlich sinnlos
so mal welchen zufügt
die debug ausgabe ist wirklich nicht sonderlich erhellend irgendwie
gucken wir mal mit unserem tollen sqlite explorer ob da jetzt was drin steht
ja da ist es hier guckt da
eben gerade tracking all die das carrier ist null wahrscheinlich ist 0 dhl weil
das das erste ist was in der liste drin steht ok so dann müssen wir das jetzt
noch in unsere webseite reinkriegen ok mounted fetch und zwar wir rufen das
ganz ab von slash api slash schipp schipp münz
awaits so es sind und dann sagen wir das schipp münz ist
awaits bislot jason in der hoffnung dass das auch kein error gibt beim abrufen
schauen wir mal
anscheinend geht das und hat fehler geschmissen haben wir hier mal
netzwerken schipp münz fetsch ja funktioniert ist ja auch nicht
nichts kompliziertes bis jetzt so kann ich hier mal unseren
reload schichten wieder benutzen wir machen die wir machen die browser tools
mal unten hin weil sonst sieht man so der reload immer noch so das heißt
jetzt müssen wir unsere tabelle mal malen lassen damit und zwar mal gucken
ob ich das aus dem kopf hinkriege view vor gleich schippen in schipp münz da
man den kram weg und sagen so eine klammer zu viel schipp münz punkt carrier
zum beispiel null das ist richtig weil null ist dhl guckt guckt null null ist
moment falsche falsche app null ist dhl sieht man nämlich hier da als der
erste eintrag ist null ist dhl müssen wir noch schauen dass das dann hier
dhl drin steht und ich null aber das kriegen wir schon noch gebacken
so also schipp münz ist da wollen wir die tracking tracking all die anzeigen ja
sehr schön dann machen wir hier noch mal so was wie tr mal ein bisschen
abstecken mal ein bisschen abstand dazwischen her padding und pixels
ach nee margin auch nicht ja wie geht denn das td
wie ich mir nicht den unterschied zwischen padding und marching merken
kann ja jetzt dann dann so will ich es haben dass man ein bisschen bisschen rand
haben fünf pixels sind da glaube ich ganz ganz okay
du kannst mit erf auch den inumwert auch als dringend in der db speichern da
musst du das nicht wieder übersetzen wie da muss ich wahrscheinlich bei meinem
model irgendein attribut oder so drüber drüber schreiben
weißt du wie genau
ok status 0 update 0 karriere ja genau mit attribut dann dann suchen wir mal
danach erf core in um den ich jason nicht jason einfach nur in um
string
fad
was was brauche ich da für einen
in um es in in um es trinken genau das wollen wir haben in um es trinken
hat und model creating entity war moment was ach hier so ja soll das so machen
ich kann mal ausprobieren vielleicht funktioniert das ja mal hier wieder aus
gehen in unseren unsere datenbank gelings rein so und überschrei mit on model
creating bei der gelegenheit könnten wir eigentlich auch created ad
automatisch setzen so entity
entity dings hier wie habe ich es genannt shipment property area es
string conversion ok schauen wir mal ob das was bringt
um
moment oder um
né
Das bringt nix.
Auskern Fox ich glaube im alten Entity Framework ging das genauso, aber ich weiß nicht wie
das in EF Core geht.
Irgendein Vorteil muss sie aber ja haben.
So schau mal, doch.
Das wird richtig gespeichert.
Ah, ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt.
Also es ist vollkommen egal wie das gespeichert wird in der Datenbank, der JSON-Converter
der JSON-Converter beim bei der Antwort hier, der schickt da Null zurück.
Wartet mal, 100% Discord ausmachen, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Äh, was, was, was spackt der, was, wow, hab ich, hab ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht?
Ach, ich hab die Datenbank noch auf, das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren.
So, wenn wir jetzt mal hier reingucken, genau, ha, der JSON-Converter ist das Problem und
nicht wie das Ding in der Datenbank gespeichert wird.
Der JSON-Converter konvertiert das als Int und nicht als String, das heißt wir können
den Kram hier schon mal wieder rausschmeißen.
Jetzt müssen wir das irgendwie unserem JSON-Converter beibringen, dass der das richtig macht.
Spillnet Core Enum JSON String, also im Prinzip hab ich eben aus Versehen sogar schon das
richtig eingegeben.
JSON-Serializer-Settings-Enum-As-String, JSON-Serializer-Settings-Enum-As-String, nee, wir wollen es deserialisern.
Enum-Names-instead-of-Int-Values, jawoll, zeig ich her.
JSON-Converter-Type-of-String-Enum-Converter, ja, das klingt, das klingt gut, das klingt
gut, das klingt gut, Enum-Member, ja, JSON-Converter-Type-of-String-Enum-Converter, ja, JSON-Converter-Type-of-String-Enum-Converter,
das können wir da drüberschreiben, okay.
Was schreibt der Github-Typ hier noch?
Add JSON-Options, Options-Serializer-Settings-Converter.
Settings, Konverter
Hab ich da irgendwie Zugriff drauf? Ne, haha, das bringt da gar nichts mehr
Leute, das das geht so gar nicht, weil
Das ist ASP.NET Core 3 hat keinen, verwendet kein JSON.NET mehr, das funktioniert so gar nicht
Also wenn ich das jetzt hier
Eintrage
Hier, hier wollen wir es ja haben. Sagt, da geht nicht
Oder doch
Geht auch mit dem neuen
Use System Text, JSON Serialization
Okay, was auch immer, ich hab jetzt für Dinger einbinde, Value Conversion Internal. Ne, ne, das wollen wir nicht
Ne, ne, das funktioniert so nicht
Was, was kann ich da angeben, JSON Converter? Hallo, JSON Converter
Das ist, das ist Preview 7. Type, off
Hawk. Oh, äh, Moment, ach da
So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt, jetzt funktioniert
Ah, guck mal da, jetzt steht DHL drinne
Ah, überhaupt kein Problem, Eats AF
Okay, können wir weiter basteln, also DHL, DHL blablabla
So, updated
Wie hab ich das genannt, updated add
Ne, created add, hab ich das genannt?
Created add, das müssen wir mal gucken, wo ich die Zahl jetzt herkrieg
So, und Status, ähm, Status krieg ich aus meiner History
Also, jetzt muss ich jetzt irgendwie sowas wie, History
Allerdings ist die History leer in dem Fall
Die History ist leer, weil, ne, gut, da gibt's keinen Eintrag
Das ist eklig, das ist eklig, das ist eklig, das ist eklig
Die History ist leer, weil, ne, gut, da gibt's keinen Eintrag, das ergibt irgendwo Sinn
History, wir machen das mal anders, wir wollen, dass da zumindest immer eine leere Liste drinne ist
Wenn, nicht null, null, null abfangen ist immer doof, wenn's nicht wirklich unbedingt nötig ist
Genau, da, Moin Max, hatte Donnerstag meinen ersten Ausbildungstag, wie hieß mein Azubi-Kollege wohl?
Genau, Max, tja, das ist doch, Max sind überall
So, ähm, jetzt müssen wir eben noch sagen, Table Style machen wir 100% von der Seite
100%, ah
Ah
Gut, ähm, so, jetzt wird's ein bisschen unschön, weil, wenn, wenn das hier größer null ist
Dann zeig ich mal, weiß was ich, äh, äh, zeig ich denn da mal an
Irgendwas, so, und wenn das, und wenn das nicht größer null ist, dann zeig ich an Pending
Das heißt, er hat noch nicht, also wenn hier Pending drin steht, dann hat er noch nicht den aktuellen Status zu dieser Sendungsnummer abgerufen
Anstatt irgendwas soll er natürlich später an der Stelle drinstehen, was er abgerufen hat
Aber probieren wir das erstmal so aus, äh, und Created Ed soll natürlich auch nicht drinstehen, sondern der updated Zeitraum
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal, dass wir das ordentlich aktualisieren gleich im Hintergrund
Das, das reicht erstmal
So, als nächstes sorgen wir jetzt dafür, dass wir Sendungsnummern submitten können
Das heißt, wir brauchen eine Form mit einem Submit-Knopf
Und dann brauchen wir einen Input Radio Button oder eine Checkbox
Sondern einen Radio Button, weil wir wollen immer nur eins aktiv haben
Man kann die Sicherheitslücke schon förmlich riechen
Frontend Sicherheitslücken jucken doch eh keinen
Wenn dein Server ein Problem hat, ist eher schlecht
Type Radio Button
Ja, cheat so in der Richtung, dass man das aufklappen kann
Oder dass man es anklicken kann und es geht ein Pop-Up auf, irgendwie sowas
So, Radio Button, oh Gott, wie funktioniert der Kram nochmal, irgendwie Name
Und da muss man jetzt eingeben, hier, Carrier, was das sein soll
Wenn ich jetzt mehrere Buttons habe, geht nur einer, ne, genau
Es geht immer nur einer mit dem gleichen Namen, stimmt's? Ja, stimmt
So, und das hier ist Value, das hier oben ist DHL
Chat über Code, echt, zeig mal her, ja
Wir können das hier sogar ein bisschen kleiner machen, dann sieht man hier mehr
Cute Chat
So, jetzt müssen wir irgendwie gucken, wie wir den Kram stylen können, hier oben
Weil da hätte ich gerne ein DHL-Logo und da hätte ich gerne
Da hätte ich gerne ein Hermos-Logo
War das Voice-to-Weep-Voice, ja klar
Ja, mittlerweile so viel Blödsinn da drinnen
Wobei, mein Lieblings-Text-to-Speech ist immer noch einmal das da
Und, und der hier
So, wie stylt man jetzt ordentlich Radio-Buttons?
Sind wir jetzt wieder maxkrasse CSS-Künste gefragt, hier
Das kann ich mit Cola hinterher machen, das sieht jetzt auch wieder besser aus
Übrigens Leute, hab ich euch schon erzählt
Wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt, könnt ihr das Ganze kostenlos verbinden mit eurem Twitch-Account
Und dafür bekommt ihr im Monat kostenloses Twitch Prime-Loot
Und ihr könnt einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Sub unterstützen
Dem Streamer bringt das die ganz normalen Vorteile, wie jeder andere Sub auch
Plus mit dem Bonus, dass es euch nichts kostet
Nur mal so angemerkt, ich hatte auch gestern Geburtstag
Vielleicht soll ich das jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal erwähnen, wenn ich grad schon Zell-Out mache
Das heißt, wenn ihr noch einen Twitch Prime-Loot habt, hab ich natürlich nichts dagegen einzuwenden
Wenn ihr das, wenn ihr damit macht, was ihr wollt natürlich
So, ähm, weiter im Text
Monka-Windows
So, Pending
Das funktioniert tatsächlich
Pong
Jumper 2020
Flamongo
Auch am Start
Dankeschön für die beiden Prime-Subs
Hallo, Portal Ghana
Portail Ghana
Würde gern Subscriben, geht aber nicht, jaja, macht nix, kannst natürlich auch so gucken, ne
So, aber wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben
Hab ich vor
Was hab ich jetzt gerade gemacht, hab ich vor lauter Zell-Out vergessen
Ach ja, genau, ich wollt die Radio-Buttons stylen, wie stylt man ordentlich Radio-Buttons
Input
Wir müssen Google gucken
CSS Radio-Buttons
How to create custom checkbox and Radio-Buttons
Benutz Vue Etify
Das ist in irgendeinem CSS Vue, CSS Framework oder sowas
Sieht ganz hübsch aus
Brauchen wir da echt ein CSS Framework für ein bisschen Tabelle
Gibt ja zig CSS Frameworks im Endeffekt
Components, haben die hier irgendwo ne Anzeige
Was sie alles für Komponenten haben
Wollen wir mal, dass ich da so ne Übersicht angucken kann
Das ist mir viel zu komplizierter, muss ich das jetzt als Framework mir merken
Label-Container-Span
Nee, das macht man bestimmt so nicht mehr
Wir suchen mal nach Checkbox, weil Checkbox werden wahrscheinlich mehr gestylt
How to create custom checkbox
Das haben wir uns anscheinend schon mal angeguckt
Input-Type-Checkbox
Hätte ich auch so drauf kommen können
Aber bloß nicht Checkbox, sondern
Radio-Button
Und schon ist der Radio-Button groß
So
Border
Machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie Kanal 20 Pixel Solid Blue
Funktioniert nicht
Warum funktioniert das nicht
Warum geht die Größe, aber ich kann keinen Border drum herum machen
Jetzt sowas wie Background-Color
Geht auch nicht
Warum nicht
Da braucht man die Big-CSS-Brains
Checkbox-Just-CSS
Appearance-None
Copy-Paste
Easy as fuck
Das scheint schon mal zu funktionieren
Jetzt machen wir erstmal alles weg, was so aussieht, als brauchen wir es nicht
Webkit-Appearance
Kann man nicht einfach Appearance nennen?
Nee, anscheinend nicht
Webkit-Appearance
Gibt es dann auch sowas wie Mods-Appearance?
None
Kann man nicht einfach Appearance nehmen?
Images instead of Radio-Buttons
Ja, die machen da aber irgendwie den Label drum herum
Aber das ist trotzdem ein ganz guter Hinweis, dieses Stack-Overflow-Posting
Wir stellen das erstmal ordentlich ein
Wir wollen jetzt erstmal Höhe und Breite haben
64, 64 Pixels
Wir wollen ja dann ein Hintergrundbild mit dem DHL-Logo drin haben
Die Background-Color ist egal, die brauchen wir nicht
Border, 2 Pixels
Border brauchen wir auch nicht
Shadowbox brauchen wir eigentlich auch nicht
Padding und so
Auch alles nicht
Vielleicht den Radius mal gucken
So, jetzt ist es durchsichtig, natürlich, klar
Background-Image
Slash-Image, Slash, was haben wir da gehabt?
Hermes-PNG, ne?
Bam, da ist es
Fast
Das Hermes-Logo ist 128, 128
Da ist es drin
So, das wollen wir jetzt natürlich nicht den kompletten Radio-Button
Sondern die Radio-Button braucht natürlich eine Class
Der kriegt Class-DHL
Und der kriegt Class-Hermes
So, ähm
Dann machen wir hier mal das alles default
Guck mal hier, abgerundete Ecken haben wir sogar, wenn wir das so machen
Das machen wir mal weg und dann sagen wir hier
Dann haben wir hier DHL und dann sagen wir Hermes
So, sehr gut
Gut, und dann brauchen wir hier noch DHL und ich glaube das war ein JPG
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt eigentlich schon
Guck mal, man kann es sogar markieren
Das sieht doch jetzt eigentlich schon mal ganz nice aus
So, Outline haben wir die Null, wenn das geht
Ja, so und jetzt brauchen wir nämlich den Kram hier, wo dann Checked dahinter steht
Hier Checked
Ähm, hier, Checked
Das ist, wenn man das angeklickt hat
Muss man da sowas dahinter machen? Nee, ne, einfach mal so
Checked
Ähm, und da sagen wir jetzt Border
Solid
Zwei Pixel und Blau
Ha, guckt euch das mal an
Ok, das backt ein bisschen rum, aber
Im Prinzip ist es doch ganz gut, oder?
Wenn wir jetzt vielleicht schon einen ordentlichen Farbton dafür finden
Ja, Solid White, dann backt es auch nicht mehr rum
So, eigentlich ganz nice
Wir müssen nur gucken, dass wir es ein bisschen kleiner kriegen, weil so ist das zu fett
Ähm, wir machen
Und jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass wir das Bild resicen können
Resicen wir ein Bild hier, Background
Image
Image, ne, Background
Resicen wir ein Bild, Clip
Color, Position
Position vielleicht
Center
Ah, fast, wie kann man das skalieren, irgendwie Scale
Size, ah, guck mal da
64 Pixel, 64 Pixel
Aha, POC
Ein gescales Hermes-Logo
Und Background Size, Contain
Ah, interessant
Das hab ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen
Oh, schön, sehr schick
Sagt doch, der Auskern-Fox ist unser absoluter CSS-Pro hier
Der macht da keiner was vor
Wir brauchen doch eine Monka, Monka CSS
Monka Windows haben wir schon
Oh, das gefällt mir, das ist schick
Ok, die Farbe außen drum sieht noch ein bisschen hässlich aus
Irgendwie, Color Picker
So, was schönes raus, Color Picker
Ein schönes Blau
Gut, das sieht man bei Hermes jetzt nicht richtig gut, ne?
Ah, komm, wir können damit, oder wir machen damit
Gucken wir mal wie es aussieht mit Black
Das ist auch ok, oder?
Ja, das ist ganz schick, das war mal schwarz
Was machst du denn beruflich, also arbeitest du dort auch mit.net?
Selten, selten, mach mal Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf
Wir haben da sogar einen eigenen Clip dafür, wo ich das erklärt hab, was ich mach
Schwarzer Rand mit Schatten drum herum
Ach was, wir müssen es jetzt nicht übertreiben
Ich mein wir gewinnen heute keinen Schönheitswettbewerb damit
Geht ja einfach darum zu gucken, ob es funktioniert
So, also wir können jetzt auswählen, ob DHL Hermes
Wir können das Ganze Submitten
Jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Inputfeld für die eigentliche Trackingnummer
Also brauchen wir hier ein Input, Text
Sieht ganz schön hässlich angeordnet aus, oder?
Dem kann man bestimmt irgendwie sagen
Irgendwie sowas wie Position
Gibt es nicht sowas wie Vertical, Vertical Align
Sieht schon mal besser aus
Nehmen wir mal einen Break dazwischen, bisschen Abstand
Ich mein er weiß, als letzter Schluss ist es nicht
Das machen wir dann oben als Popup, also machen wir hier einen Button für hinzufügen
So, jetzt haben wir hier was, das braucht als Name
Braucht das Tracking ID, haben wir es glaube ich genannt
Und dann braucht es noch einen Placeholder
Tracking ID
Ja, ist nice, ist schick
Jetzt möchte ich das hinzufügen können und Submitten
Wir haben ja noch mehr DHL Codes zum Tracking
Ich glaube das funktioniert, DHL Track Trace
Hier war es doch immer
Scheint es zu geben, aber gibt noch keine Infos zu
Ist auch gut
Oder war das eine falsche Tracking Nummer vielleicht
Sowas hätten wir noch zu bieten hier
Das da, DHL Submit, bamm, funktioniert nicht, weil mein Backend das nicht checkt
Und zwar checkt mein Backend das nicht, weil es Jason haben will höchstwahrscheinlich
Genau
Oder kann man jetzt entweder From Body sagen oder From Form, eins von beiden geht glaube ich
Ich glaube From Body ist dynamisch je nachdem was es für einen Content Type hat
Schauen wir mal
Sehen wir ja klar ob es funktioniert
Unsupported Media Type, ja ja, bla bla bla
From Form
Ah, funktioniert, wir haben was angelegt
Allerdings ist das ganz schön Fail was wir angelegt haben
Wir haben nämlich vergessen die Zeit zu setzen
Da sehen wir schon das nächste
Wir brauchen unbedingt noch einen Delete Knopf
Weil sonst ist der Mist permanent drinnen
Also wir brauchen noch einen Delete Knopf
Delete sollte ja schon schneller implementiert sein in dem Controller
Delete, wir brauchen noch einen Delete Knopf
Den Delete Knopf machen wir hier vorne daneben, daneben das shipment machen wir den
Delete Knopf
Ein Button
Funktioniert, natürlich ist er nicht gestylt, aber das ist schon ganz ok
Wir haben die Material Design Icons glaube ich schon eingebunden hier drinnen
Das heißt die könnten wir verwenden
Class
Cherry Lies, nee, oh fuck
Ich weiß gar nicht wie es Leute gibt die sich das alles aus dem Kopf merken können
Icons
Icons irgendwie was weiß ich, Light oder so gab es da
Moment wie ging das nochmal
Ja
Da ist bestimmt irgendein Beispiel zu drinnen
Ach nee Punkt Material Icons brauchen wir
Worum war das
Jetzt brauchen wir einen Icon was es gibt
Oder auch nicht
Können wir uns das nicht hier abgucken wie ich das hier gemacht habe
Ja da
Material Icons
Dann habe ich das genommen
Na ja geht doch
Man muss einfach nur einen Icon nehmen was es auch gibt
Kennst du ein Programm mit dem man unter Linux ein 6 in 4 Tunnel zwischen zwei Servern herstellen kann? Nein aus dem Kopf nicht
Aus dem Kopf nicht
Ok gibt es vielleicht die Lead
Direkt
Ahja der Mülleimer genau
Der Mülleimer
Jetzt können wir uns das CSS vom Auskern Fuchs abgucken was wir das letzte Mal
Fuck
Meine Rider Evaluation ist abgelaufen
Gucken wir jetzt einfach mal rein wie wir das das letzte Mal gemacht haben
Wie haben wir da unser
Ja
Klick Button Delete
Wie haben wir das
Button Delete
So haben wir das gemacht das haben wir irgendwie
Class Message Class User
Na gut das machen wir jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher was benutzt du das ist ein Gnome Terminal
So diesen Button den machen wir jetzt erstmal weg
Button
Wir machen wir machen dann auch noch ein extra CSS Pfeil weil das ganz schön geschwuppel hier JavaScript Zeug HTML
CSS alles in einem Pfeil drin
Background
Transparent
Border
Kann man auch Transparent machen
Ja das ist doch schon mal ganz schick
Kann man jetzt einfach sowas sagen wie Float Right geht das
Nee
Oder
Dann und dann
Wie kriege ich denn das Ding jetzt in die Mitte
Wie kriege ich das Ding jetzt in die Mitte vom Text
Wahrscheinlich muss ich dann Diff drinne machen
Oder so
Nee
Hallo Rein der Kill BF
Load Left auf der Tracking Number
Geht das nicht geht das nicht einfach so
Center
Nee geht damit vertical allein nicht
Wie kriege ich den Button da jetzt rechts daneben
Display Flex
Allerdings nicht auf dem Button sondern auf dem Container oben drüber
Keine Ahnung wer macht das jetzt mehr
Class
Ah ja da kommen wir in der Sache doch schon näher
Ah so ist das doch sehr sehr schick
Da machen wir noch irgendwie ein Padding rein von 5 Pixels
Nee brauchen wir kein Padding nur Margin von 5 Pixels brauchen wir
Nee was
Doch nee wir brauchen brauchen wir ein Padding
Nee warte
Ach nee der Button
Der Button braucht das der Button
So der Button kriegt das jetzt mal weg und dann kriegt er hier einen
So ist doch eigentlich ist doch ok
Kann ich jetzt kann ich irgendwie sagen ich will den löschen Button immer rechts immer rechts also kann ich irgendwie sowas wie
Du kannst noch justify Konter jetzt kommen jetzt kommen aber hier die
Übels krassen CSS Bros an
Tatsache ich weiß zwar nicht so genau was ich da jetzt gemacht habe aber ich finde das echt sehr schick
Das ist online auf GitHub dann ja
Ich finde das sehr schick das gefällt mir jetzt echt gut
So und da machen wir jetzt nur noch den Button
Den Button machen wir jetzt nicht Background Transparent sondern
Achso Nee
Fond Fond Nee nicht
Color
Color Red
So
Oder nicht Red
Aber nicht Red
Wo haben wir unseren Color Tracker eben gehabt
Color
Nicht Color Tracker
Color Picker
Guide to Flexbox
Das mein problem ist ich mache nicht so viel Webseiten Zeug
Ich vergesse das immer zwischen den Sachen wo ich es mache wenn ich dann wieder sehe
Stelle ich fest das hast du schon mal irgendwo gesehen
Ich habe mir auch schon guides angeguckt Guide to Flexbox wie du da geschrieben hast
Ich habe mir es gab auch ein richtig gutes Video zu irgendwie so Ultimate Guide zu Flexbox und sowas
Aber ich mache das einfach nicht jeden Tag und wenn man das nicht jeden Tag oder öfters mal macht
Dann vergisst man das immer wieder dazwischen
Machen wir mal sowas hier
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie mein Pepega Board oder
Mit dem Mülleimer und dem
Sieht recht ähnlich aus was wir da gebastelt haben
Okay
Sehr schön
Dass der hier aber kurz blau drumrum wird kann ich kann ich mit leben wenn man ihn anklickt
So und jetzt müssen wir das ganze löschen
Das heißt
Was für Musik da im Background läuft da läuft gerade
Beautiful Chillstep Collection
Juni 2017
Wir gucken mal ob es dann auch mehr von gibt Beautiful Chillstep Collection
Gibt es dann auch 2018
Jaja Hintergrund
Kann man auch mit leben
So jetzt müssen wir dem noch beibringen dass man da draufklickt dass er den Kram löscht
Das heißt ich brauche den Event an diesem Button
Wo ist der Button
Da ist der Button
Klick
Und wir hier irgendwie Delete
Delete
Es war Delete Shipment
So da sagt jetzt hier oh hier Delete Shipment
Ups es war das Doppelpunkt
Ich glaube es war Doppelpunkt
Zumindest die Methode gibt es ja auch gar nicht
Methods
Delete
Sehen wir gleich ob das passt
Doppelpunkt klick
Anscheinend war es Doppelpunkt klick
Block
Jaja
Schauen wir mal
Oder auch nicht
Das war ein Add
Das ist einfach das was ich nicht so oft mache ich vergesse die Details immer
Mir ist prinzipiell die ganze Zeit klar was ich machen will
Aber okay
Ein Klick
Event anklicken
Ja das brauchen wir nicht das ist die alte Schreibweise das habe ich mir gedacht das geht anders
Doch da war es doch Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt onClick Doppelpunkt onClick war das
Doppelpunkt klick
Kann das sein das er nicht mehr klickt
Das ging doch so wir können einfach abgucken wie wir es hier gemacht haben
Klick
AddClick okay es ist doch Add nicht Doppelpunkt
AddClick
Jaja da ist doch ein Add
Vielleicht darf ich es nicht Delete nennen
Sondern Delete
Nee das ist die Kurzschreibweise das ist okay
Ah jetzt geht es ich darf es nicht Delete nennen Delete ist anscheinend Reserved für irgendwas
Okay also Fetch
Async brauchen wir das ganze
Fetch so AP
Dann die ID
Ja wahrscheinlich Keyword Delete ja das ist irgendwie so
Die Zeit hat man manche Sachen einfach im Gefühl das wenn sie nicht gehen und sieht alles richtig aus dass es dann vorher was anderes sein könnte
Okay
Aber gucken wir mal ob das Delete funktioniert was er da macht
So jetzt müssen wir ihm noch sagen dass wir
Method
Wollen wir Delete
Warte mal geht doch so
Delete muss man vielleicht so schreiben
Okay dann schauen wir mal ob er das jetzt macht
Network
Okay
Ah da ist weg nice
Okay funktioniert Pog
Welche Nummer war das denn jetzt die da
Die da
Nee ich muss keinen Await hinschreiben das ist einfach so Fire and Forget
Alternativ nee haha ich weiß wir machen das anders
Wir
Wir könnten Redirect noch
Es gibt ja sowas irgendwie so wie Follow oder Redirect
Nee
Redirect
True
Dann leitet er einen nämlich um wenn einen das Server umleitet
Das wollen wir übrigens schon mal nicht beim Adden dass der uns auf diese Seite schmeißt
Um geht es jetzt nicht mehr
Ist doch Awaiten aber es ergibt doch eigentlich keinen Sinn warum soll ich es Awaiten müssten
Was heißt das Redirect das irgendwie kaputt macht
Das Redirect macht das kaputt
Ich weiß nicht so genau warum
Aber ich meine wir können wenn wir jetzt Awaiten können wir einfach sagen hier wenn
If result result code
Nee was kriegen wir da zurück Status Code okay
Status
Sag ich was gibt es da 200
Übrigens wir machen vorher noch mal was anderes
Wenn ich was Edde
Wenn ich was Edde will ich Redirecten auf die Hauptseite wieder weil ist das komische Debug
Den brauche ich an der Stelle gar nicht
Aber hier nochmal Stop
Wenn man einen Post schickt
Wenn man einen Post schickt will ich
Redirect
Auf dahin
So
Defaultenmäßig nimmt er DHL das ist auch gut
Jetzt hat er mich Redirect habt ihr gesehen
Redirect
Ach das muss ich auch noch checken dass man keine Sachen doppelt hinzufügen kann
So
Jetzt will ich nur noch dass er mich redirectet also wenn
Das habe ich natürlich nicht geguckt ich noob
Was kriege ich für eine Antwort beim löschen 200 okay also wenn
Wenn Status 200 ist dann
Redirecten wir mal gucken wir das offiziell hier
Fetch redirect
Response redirected
Fetch
Fetch function response
If response ah okay da müssen wir das gar nicht haben
Dann können wir einfach hier so gucken response result
Redirected
If redirected
Dann
Detecting redirects disallow redirects
Kann ich jetzt einfach
Jetzt weiß ich woher war das allow redirect bezieht sich über nicht drauf überhaupt nicht drauf dass der
Der browser redirected wird sondern nur dass der Fetch
Redirect folgen würde
Also sprich ich mache den Fetch ich mache den irgendwie ein get oder so
Auf eine Uhr und die redirected mich dass er dann quasi die die Uhr noch mal Fetch auf die redirected habe
Ach das
Ja da muss ich dann muss ich von Hand von Hand
Von Hand machen
Vielleicht gibt es dann aber auch einen Abweg
Reload ja wir können Reload machen stimmt wir können wirklich einfach einen Reload machen
Da hast du hast du recht ne wie geht das Window Reload Reload
Und es ist wirklich Location ja Location Reload genau
Weil wir sind ja schon auf der Seite
Gucken wir mal Submit
An wenn man das auch drin ist
Ah wir redirecten ja auch nicht
Wir redirecten ja auch nicht
Da müssen wir das hier noch mal einstellen dass wir auch hier redirecten beim löschen
Ach wir returnen das was wir gelöscht haben
Gut das ist
Redirecten auch mal dahin
Wobei ganz ehrlich
Machen wir nicht
Wir sagen ihm einfach
Ben wir scheißen auf redirecten wir machen das wirklich so wie wir es ursprünglich
Weil das was
Was
Stba42 geschrieben hat das wollte ich ja eben schon machen mit 200
Hab ich mir gedacht ok wenn da auch schon redirect drin steht können wir das checken aber ist ja egal
Wir können einfach können einfach so gucken wenn erfolgreich dann
Weg
Bäm zack
So und jetzt machen wir noch mal eine Sache die wahrscheinlich
Sehr hässlich empfunden wird
Wir lassen den mal alle
Sekunde dass wir den mal die sachen neu laden
Dass ich mitkriege wenn was ist
Ach hier
Leg zwar um erstmal laden ein bisschen aber es ist immer aktuell
Wenn wir das dann fertig gebaut haben machen wir das noch ein bisschen schöner mit dem mit dem mit dem
Permanente verbindung zum server und gucken wenn also wir lassen uns dann vom server Bescheid sagen wenn sich was
Aktualisiert hat und fetschen das nicht jede sekunde
Wäre nicht gleich gleich gleich besser doch wir sind es ist ja javascript stimmt wir sind javascript
Ich muss doch mal erst mal einmal
Einmal muss ich den graben direkt beim start ausführen
Ok nice das funktioniert ganz gut
So pending da kann ich löschen sehr schön das gefällt mir schon mal gut
Das reicht auch erstmal um weiter zu machen
Jetzt versuchen wir mal was abzufangen so ha ne eins müssen wir noch machen
Eines falsche App wir müssen hier im Controller noch setzen beim hinzufügen
Die Uhrzeit von dem Ding
Created ad datetime now
So ist gut passt
Und das da gefällt mir auch noch nicht die Zeit müssen wir auch mal parsen wieder
Das können wir hier machen
So ja geh weg
Können wir hier machen da können wir hier sagen
Created ad new date das habe ich mir gemerkt dass das das javascript die
Dot net timestamp ganz gut parsen kann und umgedreht dort nicht kann java timestamps ganz gut
Pasen ohne dass man großen akt machen muss jetzt können wir sowas machen wie to local
Oder auch nicht lokale stringen sieht doch schon gleich viel schöner aus
Erwörker da hast du recht die simplere variante sich leider von neu
So ok das passt also ich kann jetzt mal Sachen hinzufügen und er fügt einmal
Beim starten zum testen was hinzu und jetzt würde ich sagen prüfen wir im
Hintergrund ob es updates von dhl gibt also das wird jetzt ein bisschen
Komplizierter aber mal aus
Ich mache das nicht mit view weil das eine super tolle single page application sein
Sollte sondern weil ich es einfach viel einfacher finde als mit etwas anderem
Ich werde es dann aber auch so machen in zukunft also ich werde das ding nicht jede
Sekunde neu laden lassen ich mache dann irgendwie eine in eine websocket verbindung
Oder sowas der bescheid sagt wenn sich auf dem server was geändert hat
Oder dann immer seine lokalen lokalen sachen mit aktualisiert
So ok also brauche einen neuen ordner
Neue klasse brauche mal neue klasse gibt es da abkürzung so klasse
Die nennen wir jetzt mal tracker in anbetracht der tatsache dass ich immer schlecht bin
In der namensfindung für sowas background tracker heißt der jetzt
Und der muss ein interface implementieren weil das sp.net kursor will
Nämlich ihosted service
So wenn ich das habe
Implement interface
Die turn wir faken einfach dass wir fertig sind jetzt mal
Und wenn ich das habe startet das nämlich im hintergrund
Und also beim start mit mit der anwendung automatisch im hintergrund
Und hat mit der mit dem restlichen mit der restlichen sachen nichts zu tun
So ist das
Und wir gehen das aus das
Service background
Background tracker habe ich das genannt
So jetzt startet er den kram im hintergrund und da drinne
Können wir jetzt die abfragen machen
Zu unserem dhl zeug
Und den dhl tracker den haben wir hier gehabt den haben wir schon gemacht vor ein paar tagen
Den hatten wir hier irgendwo dhl test
So da ist unser dhl gedöns
Wir ignorieren jetzt mal was wir hier gemacht haben und kopieren nur mal diesen
Diese dhl tracker klasse darüber
Und auch klar wieder zu dhl tracker
Das ist hier mal in line in dem feil stehen weil das ist ja nicht so lang
So dhl klei htp kleint brauchen wir task shipment
Gucken wir mal
J object pass ja gut das können wir jetzt hier nicht mal verwenden
Key liegt ja so war so war komplett so war toller ap key liegt den haben wir on stream live erstellt
Und ich habe auch ich es ist auch problematisch
Ich habe auch meine ip permanent hier liegt
IP liegt
Wir wollen übrigens gar nicht ein shipment oder ein shipment brokers zurückgeben
Wie verwendet man den neuen asp.net core parser
Wie geht das habe ich noch nie verwendet
System text json serializer
Mal gucken wie das funktioniert
json
parser json
json reader
Warum leckt man intellisense
Zu viel zu viel machine learning im hintergrund mittlerweile
Okay ich habe keine ahnung wie man diesen neuen asp.net core 3 json
Drei pars json
Ja zeig mal her
Zeig her
Wie funktioniert es
Try new system text json ap
Ja
Serializer nick ich will ich will eigentlich einfach nur auf ein paar keys zu greifen
Using
json document pars ja das will ich haben json document pars
Das will ich haben
Mal gucken wie es jetzt weiter geht
Wie kann ich jetzt weiter darauf zugreifen json element
In root element
Get property
Dann hätte man auch mal den index überschreiben können oder
Root element
Get property
Get
Object
So vielleicht
Shipments
Null
Das ist aber nicht schön
Da gefällt mir das andere aber besser
Die kacke aus
Ich das immer an
What face
Lackli as fuck
New shipment progress
Pass das json noch eine klasse
Ziemlich eklig aus
Aber mit den klassen ist doch da brauche ich eine klasse unter klasse wieder
Get property
Get description
Ach ne
Dann brauchen wir noch
Updated
Kannst du in den map rein passen
Das ist eine gute frage
Ich habe noch eine andere Idee vielleicht kann ich dir in den dynamic dynamic object rein passen
Probieren wir tatsächlich mal aus
In dem unabhängigen projekt davon
Also das müssen wir jetzt nicht in unserer web anwendung ausprobieren
Was ist mit meinem headset los
Genau probieren wir das mal aus hier mit
Wahrscheinlich weil sie konsolen anwendung ist kann ich sie nicht drin verwenden
Probieren wir gleich mal aus ob man das in den map passen kann
So dann haben wir hier
Status
Hallisens leckt übelst rum
Was macht microsoft denn da mit der ekotisch des man
Status
Dann
Das kannst du ja vergessen ich glaube ich muss mal special studio neu starten
Ich bin aus krankheit
Maschinenlernen genau
So viel maschinenlernen im hintergrund
Du verstehst nur bano wenn es ums programmieren geht
Das kann ich nachvollziehen auf jeden fall
Ich verstehe auch oftmals nur Bahnhof
Obwohl ich das schon seit 15 jahren mache
Oder länger
So ungefähr seit dotnet 2 damals rausgekommen ist
Dotnet framework 2 man war in 2014 oder so
Und bisschen davor habe ich ja auch schon angefangen
Also ich programmiere schon eine weile
Und ich verstehe auch vieles nicht
Message
Contains delivery vehicle
Dann ist es in
In delivery genau
Status
Delivery zack
Und das letzte der default ist es ist in transit was anderes kann es gar nicht sein
In transit okay
Mal gucken ob die dhl ob dieses dhl zeug jetzt im hintergrund funktioniert
Da bin ich ja mal echt gespannt das können wir wirklich vereinfachen so
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das mit diesem neuen jason parser richtig funktioniert
Jason parser
Probieren wir das einfach mal initial aus
Ich finde es auch nicht schlecht ich finde ich bin also jason dotnet kann halt alles irgendwie hat aber dafür als 100.000 möglichkeiten
Irgendwas zu machen
Ich finde es ich finde es prinzipiell gut dass es einen neuen eingebauten jason parser gibt
Okay wir machen jetzt unser übliches debug mit wobei komm
Wir setzen mal einen breakpoint
Ich bin ja normalerweise so der wisst ihr ja der command line debugger aber
New dhl tracker
Ich muss nämlich einfach mal kurz gucken ob da ob da kram funktioniert
Nachdem wir es jetzt angepasst haben
Receive info
Jetzt brauchen wir hier die tracking nummer die machen wir da hardcoded nochmal rein jetzt zum testen
So zack
Result
So
Und jetzt gucken wir mal was in er drinnen steht nachdem man gestartet haben
Funktioniert
Schippen und has been successfully delivered status ist dann updated ad am 18.07.15 48 ok also wir haben es zumindest richtig angepasst den ganzen kram
Dann können wir jetzt mal probieren ob man das vielleicht schöner parsen kann
Wir passen es jetzt einfach nochmal temp und gucken mal ob wir vielleicht dynamic dürfen wir das dynamic machen geht das
Und das vielleicht dynamic machen
Die dhl api mag nicht
Dann haben wir das jetzt das hatten wir in einem letzten stream das ist die stelle wo wir jetzt unseren try catch blog drum herum machen
Es war relativ easy mode
Wir loggen den krams noch
Die dhl api ist manchmal nicht so geschwind was steht in temp drin dynamic document shipments
Gut aber selbst wenn das dynamic ist kann ich da jetzt kann ich da jetzt so drauf zugreifen
Temp schippen was brauche ich schippen geht das so darf man das jetzt so machen wahrscheinlich nicht
Also die dhl api mag nicht oft angefragt werden das ist nicht so ist nicht so irrs irgendwie
Dhl api darf man bloß alle paar minuten mal anfragen wie es aussieht das ist natürlich kacke zum ausprobieren jetzt
Das sagt massiv
Wenn man da nur alle alle furzlange mal anfragen darf
Ne hier das funktioniert so nicht wie ich mir das gedacht habe
Was haben wir hier für varianten pass pass value was kann man damit machen
Also ich glaube viel andere viel andere möglichkeiten haben wir da nicht
Kann man das irgendwie in den dictionary irgendwie passen oder so
Ach keine ahnung ach das fällt mir jetzt nichts irgendwie gescheites ein zu
Dann lassen wir es jetzt erstmal so man funktioniert ja
Wir passen uns jetzt hier den kram aus bei der telekom raus
Gut dann können wir das jetzt machen also ich würde sagen wir führen die sache mal im hintergrund aus
Alle alle wir führen es mal alle 10 sekunden aus was bedeutet eigentlich das ad von dem string
Ist in dem fall total überflüssig das bedeutet dass du manche sachen nicht eskäpen musst
Zum beispiel hier backslash und so ist ja normalerweise escape das schmeißt das alles raus
Wie machen wir das jetzt wir machen das mit einem timer wir machen mal ein timer alle 10 sekunden
Aber meine metode hierfür dass man das das ist nicht nicht so gequetscht ist alles private void einfach mal tick tick
Objekte state null haben wir nichts zum austauschen
Du treiben das dann ab ab wann es anfängt timespan so was die timespan ist 0 ist es timespan 0
Timespan from seconds 10 das ist jetzt ein timer der alle 10 sekunden tickt und tick aufruf oder aufrufen sollte
Objekte state war das glaube ich ja sehr schön
So der timer tickt jetzt alle 10
Visual Studio gebated mich guckt euch das mal an
Ich drücke mal alt punkt
Ja wann geht es auf mixer alter mixer hört mal auf
So und das kommt jetzt hier unten in tick rein try dhl receive info ok also was wir jetzt machen
Ich glaube jetzt wird es ein bisschen komplizierter
Wir müssen jetzt gucken wir brauchen jetzt erstmal eine verbindung zur datenbank
Hast du noch die brifio incida ja das ist die aktuellste die aktuellste brifio und wahrscheinlich wird es deswegen auch rumpacken
Das ist dort net core brifio 7 visual studio brifio 16.3
Also wir brauchen jetzt hier
Die musik
Wir brauchen jetzt hier eine
Scope i scope factory oder sowas
Die sache ist die wir haben jetzt in hintergrund thread im endeffekt laufen
Der alle 10 sekunden nachgucken soll ob sich an unserem status von unseren paketen was geändert hat
Die sache ist jetzt so die um auf die datenbank zuzugreifen braucht man eine aktive session also quasi wie wenn man
Http request schickt nachdem wir ja keine http request schicken interne unsere programm wäre was auch ziemlich beknackt wäre müssten wir ihm sagen
Er soll quasi so tun als ob und dazu brauchen wir eine wie ist das i scope i scope
I service provider i factory
I service scope factory heißt der kram das ist so typisch java style
So
Wie kommst du eigentlich auf deine projekte indem ich selbst irgendwas brauche
Visual studio hör mal auf mich zu jebaiten die ganze zeit
Immer mit das anklicken gehts weg
Er schied 125 warum ich als studio will dass du dich registrierst
Ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wahrscheinlich denkt sich microsoft werden es schon kostenlos zur verfügung stellen
Dann können wir auch ein paar daten sammeln vermute ich mal
So jetzt müssen wir eine verbindung zur datenbank aufbauen
Wir müssen uns in datenbank kontext holen dass wir aus der datenbank lesen können
Was unsere aktuellen pakete unsere aktuellen pakete sind wo wir noch keinen status keinen aktuellen status von heute zu haben
So using das heißt wir müssen jetzt diese scope is scope factory nehmen und sagen create scope
Wir sind noch auf ach na wir können die neue sachen das ist übrigens auch ein neues c sharp feature
Man kann jetzt using wahr machen man braucht jetzt kein extra kein extra ein rückungs scope mehr machen
Und auch kein
Kontext
Das ist halt bisschen mühselig jetzt der ganze kram hier
App db kontext so
Jetzt werden wir den kram noch importieren und jetzt haben wir eine verbindung zur datenbank
Jetzt können wir nämlich unsere shipments aufrufen und zwar suchen wir jetzt alle shipments die für history nichts drin stehen haben
So eddie temple twitch prime pock warum nicht einfach den kontext über dependency
Injection importieren das geht nicht weil der background tracker also dieser hosted service ist als singleton registriert und meine db kontext ist als scoped registriert
Deswegen funktioniert das ganze nicht es gibt zwei varianten was man machen kann man könnte den db kontext auch als single irgendwie registrieren
Was aber irgendwie keine schöne schöne lösung ist oder man kann wahrscheinlich auch auch den hier als scope registrieren irgendwie so
Gibt gibt es eben varianten das zu machen oder die schönere variante auf jeden fall ist einfach hier drinnen wenn man drauf zugreifen will explizit einen scope erzeugen
Dann wird es auf jeden fall auch alles schön aufgeräumt immer
Und die sachen leben nicht länger als sie leben müssen
Dass er sich information von dhl zu der sendung abruft wenn alles funktioniert ok also dann sagen wir jetzt hier new dhl tracker
shipment die tracking id ach quatsch noch nicht hier kurz hin progress die tracking id von dem dhl tracker hier receive info das müssen wir nochmal alles ein bisschen anders benennen
Info hier ist jetzt der aktuelle progress von der sendung drinnen und jetzt können wir sagen shipment history add den progress
So und dann safen wir das ganze und dann sollte im web interface beim nächsten refresh wo ist das problem
Da muss man auch warten an der stelle oder wir machen es async
Ne wir können es nicht async machen das ist auch ein falsch trick wenn man hier einen scope anlegt dann kann ich kein async code verwenden weil im async returnt er und das scope ist weg
Das funktioniert an der stelle wahrscheinlich nicht müssen wir mal ausprobieren hallo lei bums da ich hab dich übrigens letztens fällt mir gerade auf jetzt wo ich den name sehe ich hab dich ja letztens ausversehen ein paar mal falsch ausgesprochen
Jetzt hab ich gerade extra drauf geachtet dass ich auch das t dabei ausspreche
Also jetzt müsste das eigentlich funktionieren
Der müsste jetzt alle 10 sekunden im hintergrund wir machen hier mal wieder
Right line debugging
Der müsste jetzt im hintergrund alle 10 sekunden den status abfragen
Und hinzufügen
Sofern es noch keinen status gibt
Das ist jetzt erstmal ganz gut
In zukunft wird das so natürlich nicht funktionieren weil ich will ja mehr als einen status speichern aber das probieren wir mal gucken ob das funktioniert ich habe so meine bedenken dass ich irgendwas vergessen habe
Pending
Okay irgendwas habe ich vergessen
Moment was
Warte mal lief das noch im hintergrund kann das sein dass es noch im hintergrund lief
Warte mal was
Ich weiß woran das liegt
Das startet den service
Das ist natürlich doof
Bevor
Bevor die datenbank angelegt ist
Das startet den service bevor die datenbank angelegt ist
Das ist natürlich doof
Dann warten wir hier einfach
Wir warten hier einfach
Einfach mal 2 sekunden
Das kann man schöner lösen das ist nicht
Ja jetzt geht das nämlich auch
Pending steht immer noch auf pending
Wollte eigentlich nicht mehr auf pending stehen
Aber das abrufen funktioniert von von infos bei der telekom
Also von der ideen sollte das eigentlich klappen
Warum sage ich eigentlich telekom von dhl
Ich habe vorhin schon ein paar mal telekom gesagt
Ich muss erst mal gucken
Also
Warum
Save ich das nicht richtig oder was
Aber warum
Was habe ich vergessen
Ich habe hier den try catch block drum gemacht
Das ist vielleicht gar nicht so clever an der stelle
Vielleicht mache ich den try catch block da drum wo ein Fehler auftreten kann
Nämlich
Hier
Also ganz sicher bin ich mir immer noch nicht warum der das
Warum er das nicht macht
Gehen wir mal den progress aus
Wobei wir gucken mal in die datenbank nicht dass er das macht und man webinterface einfach nur
Anzeigt
Ein webinterface zeigt mist an
Ich weiß woran das liegt
Okay ich kann euch sagen woran das liegt und zwar das ist das passiert mir laufend
Das passiert mir laufend wenn ich das eine weile nicht verwendet habe und zwar
Wenn ich in meinem webinterface abrufe was ist für
Ich starte gerade mal wenn ich in meinem webinterface abruf
Moment wo habe ich jetzt wo habe ich was verkackt
Hier habe ich
Moment
Wo habe ich wo habe ich irgendwas vergessen
Ich glaube ich habe was zu viel kann das sein
Ich habe ich habe ich habe was zu viel
Return task
Completed
Ne
Ach ne brauchst du gar nicht
Jetzt geht's
Ne also was ich was ich euch sagen wollte also was ich vergessen habe ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass es das ist
Wenn ich das abrufe
Alter was ist denn jetzt
Ich habe die datenbank immer noch offen
Also wenn ich das ganze starte und dann hier abrufe meine meine liste
Dann ist das problem dass ich das sieht man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch hier
Dass ich hier keine history mit kriege und warum kriege ich keine history mit
Obwohl es eine history gibt das liegt daran dass ich ihm nicht gesagt habe dass er die aus der datenbank mit abfragen soll
Da müsst ihr nämlich darauf achten das vergesse ich jedes mal wenn ich eine weile nichts damit gemacht habe
Dass wenn man hier in der metode fürs get an sachen wir sagen wir hier gibt uns alle
Alle pakete die wir haben machen eine liste draus und gibt die ans frontend zurück die sache ist die
Die shipment klasse besteht aus den einträgen hier und eine liste mit diesem shipment progress
Und standardmäßig lädt der nicht modelübergreifend die sachen wenn ich es eben nicht explizit sage
Ich muss ihm jetzt hier nämlich sagen include doch mal das model für die history
Das ist auch ganz logisch weil wenn ich in den model habe was irgendwie zig abhängigkeiten hat
Dann wird das laden unnötig lange dauern wenn ich davon vielleicht nur eins brauche
Und jetzt wird es auch funktionieren jetzt steht hier nämlich irgendwas drin
Mein status irgendwas ist natürlich bescheuert aber wir sehen das funktioniert
So und wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt eine neue tracking nummer rein paste was jetzt passieren sollte ist
Ich warte mal bis bis der background task einmal durchgelaufen ist 10 sekunden später
Fügen wir es mal hinzu 10 sekunden später sollte jetzt sollte er jetzt nachgeguckt haben
Was zu dieser tracking nummer gibt und den status aktualisieren
Bäm hat funktioniert macht der mittag und alle 10 sekunden funktioniert
Funktioniert data dass es auch war kill also das hier ist das problem ja man muss ihm sagen er soll die history
Includen an der stelle dann funktioniert das nämlich auch ich brain huge so was kann oder
Das ist so eine daten query api dass du dass du quasi besser das ist so ein bisschen du kannst quasi ohne dass du
Für jeden mist hier irgendwie eigene eigene controller methoden sonst was brauchen du brauchst kannst du besser
Deine daten deine datenbank querien wie rest ne ne über rest das ist so eine abfrage abfrage dialect
Wo du quasi über eine web in der api besser deine datenbank abfragen kannst auch mit filter und sowas
Das aber total auferkennen das braucht man hier nicht vor allem wüsste ich gar nicht wozu
Okay und jetzt schreiben wir da noch was sinnvolles rein würde ich sagen
Weil irgendwas interessiert uns ja nicht so ganz dass da irgendwas drinne steht das ist ja das ist ja langweilig
Irgendwas irgendwas juckt mich so status kommt nicht irgendwas rein sondern wir schreiben da erstmal die normale
History rein und gucken was dann da drinne steht history history null und dann den die message das müssen wir auch noch
Schöner machen zack guck mal shipment bla bla bla shipment has been successfully delivered updated am oder stimmt
Übrigens auch nicht das müssen wir noch miteinander verknüpfen das mit update stimmt stimmt stimmt auch nicht
Ja das ist nicht schön hier da muss ich mir was anderes überlegen
Also quasi ein web 2db connector so ein bisschen
Wir können wir könnten hier ein if machen wir könnten hier ein if machen hier so hier if vif
Wenn das da größer null ist
Wie ging das noch mal so
Warum geht das nicht
Warum geht das an der Stelle jetzt nicht
Hä
Ich weiß ich will aber auch was
Shipment ist noch null
Nee shipment kann nicht null sein wir sind hier in der vorschleife mit shipment drinne
Das verstehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht
Inside
Das ist anscheinend nicht so gedacht
Das geht anscheinend nicht so wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
Warum aber eigentlich nicht
Kannst du zeigen was nicht geht ja das hier kann kein ich kann kein if
Ich kann kein if in der schleife verwenden aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesehen auf dem ersten block das geht dann ist das so nicht gedacht
Dann ist das anscheinend so nicht gedacht ich meine es ist eh nicht gedacht dass man hier großartige logik drinne macht
Da nochmal rückgängig machen
Da muss ich da muss ich logik umbauen weil so viel hier oben logik inline in html machen ist eh doof
Da machen wir irgendwie irgendwie sowas wie format shipment message oder sowas
Die show ja das kann man mal ausprobieren aber ich glaube es ist schöner wenn man das so machen
Dann machen wir nämlich den kram hier drinne
Das ist glaube ich die schönere variante ist hier drinne zu machen
Computed properties das ist doch aber nur was was ich auf
Data variable bezieht habe ich doch gar nicht jetzt das geht an der stelle ich genau
This message sowas was ich auf data Sachen bezieht habe ich ja hier gar nicht format shipment message das ist doch ok so
Dann brauchen wir jetzt noch format shipment time date time
Ist dann besser ein bisschen weniger logik da oben drinne
So und da können wir jetzt nämlich auch gucken wenn wenn quasi die history length größer als das ist
Dann machen wir return das und ansonsten machen wir nämlich das history 0 updated
Jetzt funktioniert das nämlich auch gescheit
Wobei ich will da gar nicht created ad anzeigen sondern einfach nichts
Einfach nichts
Auch wenn die logik ich weiß aber nicht wie ich das machen soll
Ich weiß jetzt nicht wie ich ein computed property erstelle und dem ich auf dem ich eine variable also dem ich eine parameter übergebe dafür sind die ja nicht gedacht
Genau Methode sag ich doch
So dann passt das nämlich wenn ich das jetzt hier ein reinschmeiße dann stimmt auch die Anzeige hier
Ansonsten machen wir da mal
Wir schreiben einfach in updated nichts
So und
Hier steht pending drinnen solange der noch nichts gefunden hat okay also probieren wir es nochmal aus
10 sekunden später sollte sich aktualisieren
Ach das ist falsche
Ja ja ich habe es wieder telekom heute
Wo ist mein hintergrund thread warum läuft er nicht
Warum warum läuft mein hintergrund thread nicht wo ist er
Wo ist er warum läuft er nicht
Ist hier los
10 sekunden 10 sekunden
10 sekunden
Abgekackt oder was
Ich starte mal neu etwas sehr zu verschmerzen hat ehrlich gesagt
Irgendwie hatte das gar nicht gespeichert oder so
Jetzt hat es funktioniert okay keine Ahnung was der vorher für Probleme hatte
Was passiert eigentlich wenn ich was ende was es nicht was es nicht gibt
Da müsste abkacken bei
Genau finde da nicht
Genau da brauche ich jetzt eine logik die quasi sagt okay wenn das ein paar mal fehlgeschlagen ist
Das ist nicht auf pending sondern auf es ist kaputt
Also okay delete
Guck mal das da noch
Pending
Blub blub
Funktioniert
Fügst was hinzu
Und er ruft sich den letzten den letzten status von der telekom ab
Das ist nice das gefällt mir wir können es jetzt noch sortieren wir sortieren es noch nach updated
Das ist dann so die letzte abends handlung heute weil ich muss jetzt mal was essen ich habe hunger
Drei und halb stunden on
Es ist jetzt hätte noch ein dhl id nicht angekommen ist ja schickbar probieren wir mal aus mal gucken was er macht
Was habe ich gesagt will ich machen
Probieren wir mal aus
Was wollte ich gerade machen ich vergesse nicht gerade aber ich sitze wahrscheinlich viel zu lange hier davor
Wenn die nummer nicht gibt den status setzen ich wollte irgendwas anderes gerade machen
Kannst du die aufnahme auch so angucken
Ich bin jetzt auch gerade eingefallen ich wollte ich wollte gucken dass die dinger der richtigen reinfolge kommen
Und zwar ihr geht voll sagen oder bei absteigend
Das war oder bei
Das funktioniert
So nicht
Ja aber das funktioniert nicht doch ab wenn da nichts drinne ist
Wir sortieren das mal
Wir sortieren das erst mal nach erstelldatum
Ich werde mir in der haupt ich werde mir hier noch nen updated add in der in der main klasse machen hier noch
Hier machen wir noch nen updated add machen wir hier noch rein will es immer auf das zugreifen des letzten history eintrags ist nervig
Der informatiker ist der gedanken einfach krass dass man sich eigene apps schreiben kann klar dass man das apps nennt ist ja auch schon neu
Früher hat man einfach gesagt programm okay probieren wir mal von jäukel das die tracking nummer aus
Hier background ist das dhl
Gucken wir mal ob was findet
Funktioniert guck
Und zwar um 17 14 heute also das ganze kommt dann wahrscheinlich am montag erst
Das ist doch nice dass das so gut funktioniert oder finde ich auch
Das hat was
Aja ja klep
Ist gut mag es nicht durchdrehen
Aber ich bin echt begeistert wie gut das wie gut das klappt
Ich habe das gefühl der background service hängt sich nach einer gewissen zeit auf ne macht er nicht
Sind diese sounds eigentlich alle aus animis null gar nicht das ist das ist ne japanische text to speech seite wo das herkommt
Meinst du es gibt wirklich irgendwie eine sendung wo jemand monka es sagt
Das wäre es ja noch oder oder dings hier oder das kommt garantiert nicht aus irgendeinem video das ist japanisches text to speech
Wo haben wir uns mit einer fake email adresse registriert bei so einem japanischen text to speech provider
So leute das war anstrengend heute muss ich sagen aber wir haben doch jetzt schon mal man kann es jetzt ungefähr aus malen wo das ganze hingeht
Es war noch ein relativ primitives ui das scan von emails funktioniert noch nicht
Und es macht auch aktuell nur dhl aber es geht in die richtige richtung oder
Knautschzonen habe ich was denn p.a.p.
Monka p.a.p.
P.a.p. ist mittlerweile besser als sein ruf
Wirtschaftswissenschaft im studium hat wieder ein viewer der 3d printer hat mittlerweile der 3d printer hat null der 3d printer hat vier und der wasserkühlung
Ist immer noch an der wasserkühlung
Der hat jetzt wirklich eine woche gebraucht um die wasserkühlung einzubauen ich weiß nicht was da abgeht
Wie das ist das ist kein das ist kein bot das ist eine aufzeichnung der ist ja 24 7 online und streamt irgendwelche komischen bvl dinger
Wl hier monka smoked mit wasserkühlung grill programmiert müssen wir gucken
Es ist pländer
Ich bin immer überrascht wie viele hübsche medals es gibt hier in der sowohl über science and technology und auch generell bei den ganzen nicht gaming kategorien bei die gaming kategorien auch auf einmal nicht
Auf der arbeit haben wir davon nicht viel ab bekommen wir haben zwei stück die sehen gut aus ansonsten
Also von den medals von den typen nicht
In der arbeit sind die bei hr ja bei uns sind die tatsächlich auch zum größten teil in der finanzabteilung und bei apple bei ios app entwicklung sind bei uns auch viele
Ios app entwicklung ist bei uns voll mit medals im glas haus jetzt ja und
Ich darf mich dazu doch äußern
Ja ich wollte eigentlich gucken wir mal hausen können aber irgendwie niemand dabei
Das sieht jetzt grafisch irgendwie ein bisschen sehr minimalistisch aus
Ich will aufhören ja ich gehe jetzt was essen schieb ultra high res ja hühner hühner wo sind wo sind die schiebs wo sind die schiebs ich sehe ich sehe keine schiebs
Ich sehe nur chicken schicken snacks snacks ist irgendwie nicht das beste emote wenn man hähnchen da hat
Die meisten leute würden damit jetzt nicht assoziieren dass man einen snack für die hühnchen gibt sondern eher dass man die hühnchen snackt
Ist dann monka peter angesagt
Nes programmieren
Wasser kühlungstipp wieder
Ach keine ahnung so leute ich mach jetzt schluss
Und spiel mal ptr und dann rage ich rum und dann installier ich dann deinstallier ich gleich wieder
Rej
Also